between January 29th and February 3rd
and shared the BEI on February 4th to
enable broad sharing now according to
your complaint after virus samples were
available to the US government from the
Washington State case and potentially
even after the CDC's effort to grow the
virus and then share with the BEI
biorepository you were still seeking to
obtain a sample of the virus correct
that's true sir but we need more than
one bite I'm gonna get to that why were
the strains not available within the US
government not available to you were
they were they available to you sir I
was asking for viruses in January
because we wanted to make sure that we
had a head start on developing the
vaccine yeah no I get that and they
became available in February I believe
is February 6 through the BEI resources
then those were distributed to in
laboratories did you ask for the virus
sample from from Washington State that
was Lord of that you did
I am guarded did we asked to make sure
we had access to those viruses and they
were distributed to the right
laboratories and the right company and
where did you ultimately get the virus
that you distributed sample some of the
viruses came from the BEI resources and
at NIH and some of those viruses came
from laboratories that received the
initial seed from CDC ok that's helpful
to know in in some conversations I've
been a part of with some at NIH they
indicated that the real key here was to
get the the DNA sequence which mechina
did eventually put up I believe at the
end of December or late January and that
in terms of going after the vaccine it
was that sequencing that really mattered
most to get started on on vaccine
development and and there are other
scientists who are very distinguished
who believe that the delay in getting
the virus sample actually didn't set
them back is that an accurate assessment
or do you have a disagreement in in that
view and I know scientists disagree
so do we up here but I'm kind of hearing
that that having the sequencing really
mattered most and getting the virus
important but did
set them back in proceeding to get the
vaccine on vaccine development underway
sir the the China posted the first
sequence on January 11th I believe I
made it available January 10th or
January 11th it's important to
understand that the sequence is
available when the sequence is available
some companies with some technologies
can get started with that sequence
information vulnerable because you have
another country in their laboratories
that post it on the internet or a
database of their sequence so it could
still be challenges especially for
national security about my security of
that sequence yeah before my time runs
out its run out I was just gonna ask did
they begin efforts at that time once
they got the sequence the NIH began
efforts on a synthetic messenger RNA
vaccine candidate however without the
viruses you really cannot tell if the
neutralizing antibodies are listed by
that or your Diagnostics or your
therapeutics can actually work you can
try to synthesize of buyers with a
sequence but it's never going to be
representative of the actual virus and
we're spending billions of dollars on
drugs vaccines and diagnostics we want
to have the most credible information
possible thank you madam chair the
gentleman yields back
pleasure to recognize the gentleman from
New York mr. Engel for his five minutes
of questions
thank you madam thank you madam chair
for holding today's hearing doctor if
you were a betting man oh sorry thank
you doctor if you were a betting man
when would you bet that we would time
and that we would have a vaccine that's
a very difficult question to answer I
know that there are companies and in
academic labs working very hard normally
it takes up to 10 years to make a
vaccine we've we've done it faster in
emergency situations but from when we
had starting material in the freezer for
Ebola but for a novel virus actually
haven't been done yet that quickly so a
lot of optimism is swirling around a 12
to 18 month time frame if everything
goes perfectly we've never seen
everything go perfectly my concern is if
we rush too quickly and considered
cutting out critical steps we may not
have a full assessment of the safety of
that vaccine so it's still going to take
some time
I still think 12 to 18 months is an
aggressive schedule and I think it's
going to take longer than that to do so
12 to 18 months from now or 12 to 18
months from when this whole star at the
beginning of the year it would be 12 to
18 months from when the particular
manufacturers first received the
material or information that they needed
to start developing that vaccine is
critical to note when we say 12 to 18
months that doesn't mean for an
fda-approved vaccine that means to have
sufficient data and information on the
safety and immunogenicity not efficacy
to be able to use on an emergency basis
and that is the consideration that we
are we have in mind when we talk about
an accelerated timeline thank you I
represent in New York Bronx County in
Westchester County which at the
epicenter of the u.s. coronavirus
outbreak New Rochelle New York
well New Yorkers have really rallied
together and supported their neighbors
the administration has failed at every
turn president has sidelined our best
scientists pushed baseless conspiracy
theories and more recently prescribed
unproven remedies like Lysol to
suffering Americans since the early days
of the outbreak President encouraged
doctors to prescribe chloroquine to
suffering Americans despite a lack of
evidence supporting its use on April
24th the president's hand-picked FDA
Commissioner even came out against the
use of chlorine for Cova 19 cases dr.
what are the dangers of chlorine if
prescribed incorrectly and what happened
when you raise the issue of call the
Queen use in coronavirus patients with
HHS leadership congressman our concerns
centered around the potential use of
chloroquine in people who were infected
with this corona virus there are data of
the effective use and safety use of cork
when in malaria patients and other
patients and other indications we also
knew that there were a potential safety
risk for chloroquine to cause irregular
irregular heart rhythms and even in some
cases death so our concern was with
limited information knowledge especially
of its use in kovat 19 infected patients
and the potential for those risks then
we should make sure that any studies
with that drug were done in a carefully
controlled clinical study under close
watch 'full eye of a physician so they
could respond to a patient if they did
experience one of those adverse events
there wasn't sufficient data at that
time to support use of this drug in
patients recovered 19 without closed
position supervision when you raise that
issue of chloroquine use in coronavirus
patients with HHS leadership what
happened to you you were removed as a
director of barn is not true I'm Billy
part of the removal process for me as
initiated because of a push back that I
behave when they asked me to put in
place and expanded access protocol that
would make chloroquine more freely
available to Americans that were not
under the close supervision of a
physician and may not even be confirmed
to be infected with the corona virus the
scientists at FDA Barda and NIH and CDC
worked hard to switch that to a
emergency use authorization with strict
guardrails that the patients would be in
a hospital confirmed to be infected with
this virus under close supervision of a
doctor and who could not otherwise
participate in a randomized controlled
study my concerns were allayed
alleviated somewhat by being able to
lock that in the stockpile with those
conditions however my certain concerns
were escalated when I learned that
leadership in the department Health and
Human Services were pushing to make that
drug available outside of this emergency
use authorization to flood New York and
New Jersey with this drug regardless of
the e-way and when I spoke outside of
our government and shared my concerns
for the American public that I believe
was a straw that broke the camel's back
and escalated my removal thank you thank
you ma'am gentleman's time has expired
pleasure to recognize the gentleman from
Kentucky mr. Guthrie for his five
minutes of questions thank you very much
thank you dr. bright for being here we
appreciate it very much reading through
your your complaint let's come one point
out I think the chairman said earlier
talked about the lack of urgency and
implies the president's lack of urgency
I think most of my constituents want to
know that things are getting done and
where does the President on this and
you're having issues with that
leadership at Health and Human Services
and you're giving them recommendations
so if they're not accepting your
recognization to them I I would I think
fairly surmise they're not passing that
on to the White House so the president
probably unaware of what year you're
putting forth because it says and
reading from your complaint on face when
you think fortunately White House trade
advisor Peter Navarro shared dr. bright
sense of urgency
so I'd send the sense of urgency
so talking about the urgency in the
White House so you have a meeting with
him on Saturday he calls you back in on
Sunday we have it you prepare your
recommendations and a memo for Mick
Mulvaney chief of staff so essentially
the President and then so you meet with
you get around the leadership of HHS
meet essentially with the president
since with Mick Mulvaney him and it says
you have the meeting with Navarro on
Saturday you the Memorandum of Mick
Mulvaney ohm's Sunday and on Monday he
says the National Security Council
policy Coordinating Committee met with
dr. direct met and directed dr.
Callaghan HHS to implement Navarro's
recommendations the push by the White
House for HHS to ask more swiftly
created tension between dr. bright and
HS political leadership so it seems a I
don't know how you could be more urgent
in government than having a meeting on
Saturday a memorandum on Sunday and
actions on Monday once they got to the
president's attention the president's
level so we appreciate the president
moving forward on that I'm on the
ranking member of oh and I which the
investigations which you've testified in
front of us before and I appreciate that
very much so I'm going to look at more
of the process of putting this hearing
together and some things as we read
through your complaint the only way we
have is because you made it public and
in your complaint there are different
exhibits that you you talk about and
we're having a hearing today and there
are actually 33 exhibits referenced in
your complaint it's not public I think
we got them from majority through the
Washington Post or something like that
that's how we were made documents
available for this hearing and my
understanding so the 33 exhibits that
are not made public that would go that a
reference in your complaint would you
make those available to the committee do
you have those we'll make them available
to the committee I mean we were using
your if we're using your complaint for
this hearing we need to have the
documentation yeah you trust that the
Charak I don't have a problem with your
dress yes we will take that under
advisement and get back to you okay also
also when we read through that there may
be privacy considerations in some of the
documents so we do need to look at these
documents careful
so let me that's also firry through the
email chains that are made available
some appear complete with some sure
truly aren't there apparently not full
email chains and so you will wonder if
the context of the email would relate to
the the inference is taken from the
emails would you make all the complete
email chains available to us like to
address that as well which is a problem
is when dr. bright was removed from his
position he was locked out of his email
he does not have access to his fully
know the email chain so the the email
change that you have available we have
we have that's correct I can address not
have a full set of his email I can
address this to you and that's exactly
right so I was immediately locked out of
my email on April 20th of this year and
so I didn't have full records available
to me and that however I believe in laid
a solid foundation in my complaint as
detailed as I could be for the Office of
Special Counsel to be able to conduct an
investigation and believe it's part of
their investigation they'll be able to
access those emails and individuals to
get a full story and get the full
information so they can get to the
bottom it would have been helpful for us
as well just have you shared any of
these exhibits with the majority that's
not been shared with us in the minority
side sorry I believe you have probably
what's available in the public domain
and I believe the rest has have been
submitted to the Office of Special
Counsel and I haven't made that
available to anyone directly to the
judge to the gentleman the minority and
majority members all received the same
packet of information that was available
that was in the public domain so just
one more are there any other documents
in your possession or accessible to you
they're not included as exhibits in the
complaint but are nonetheless relevant
to your allegations if so we provide
those to the committee I believe I
provided the information I have
available to me at this point if I had
access to my email from HHS there might
be additional supporting information in
that email I do not know the status that
that's been deleted
wiped or I just haven't had access to it
since April what you have access to I
appreciate your answers thank you very
much I yield back the gentleman yields
back
pleasure to recognize the gentleman from
North Carolina mr. Butterfield for his
five minutes of questions I thank you
chairwoman and to you dr. bright thank
you sir for coming today and thank you
most importantly for your 25 years of
public service
dr. Bryant I'd like to ask you about
your efforts to address supply shortages
for administering kovat 19 tests
according to your your account as kovat
19 testing ramped up you asked for an
inventory of the strategic national
supply availability of testing supplies
including swabs viral transport
materials and extraction buffers you
learned that the national stockpile did
not stop these items after that you
learned that FDA's source of swabs was a
manufacturer in the region of Italy
which was the center of the covert 19
outbreak in Italy it is my understanding
that this information then prompted you
to reach out to a to the DoD agency that
had previously assisted your office with
international transportation of supplies
related to Ebola my question is why why
sir did your office contact DoD at this
point sir it was quite a surprise to me
that the urgent and ramped up of the
testing did not include full
consideration of all the critical
supplies needed to support that ramp up
of testing including those materials you
mentioned swabs viral transport media
buffers etc and I was a quite alarmed to
learn from sitting behind the CDC
director Redfield that we were going to
experience this shortage of swabs and I
was even more surprised that they our
strategic national stockpile plan or
have any of those in supply
so my urgency to find a solution to that
was supported by our the FDA director of
the Center for CDRH says devices and
diagnostics at the FDA
and once I confirmed that there was a
shortage and it was critical that we
find a solution and that was by
partnering with our Department of
Defense colleagues who worked with us
for the Ebola response we actually work
with them to ship doses of Ebola vaccine
from Germany to the United States so it
can be filled rapidly to respond to the
outbreak in Africa so it was a natural
occurrence or you know response for me
and my Carling Zimbardo to come up with
a solution to that critical supply ask
you this where the inner restrictions in
place in Italy that would require
secretary a czar to to move forward with
the request to DoD and what we needed to
enact that air bridge with Department
the defense was we needed our Secretary
of a secretary a czar to make a request
of the Secretary of Defense and I my eye
and my colleague dr. Garrett dispro
raised this issue with our at our senior
leadership meeting with dr. Carla keel
chairs that meeting the asper and it
clearly was not a topic of heat that he
won't discuss on that day and actually
we were rebuffed by him saying that he
did not really want to talk about swabs
right now and both dr. dispro and I
raised this concern repeatedly in that
call so knowing that it was critical and
time-sensitive and we had a critical
shortage of these swabs I placed a call
to mr. Navarro's office once again and
asked if mr. Navarro could offer some
assistance and contacting the Secretary
of Defense to get clearance for DoD to
put those airplanes in place under the
contract we have and that happened in in
a very quick turnaround a matter of
minutes with that permission from the
Secretary of Defense we were able to
start those flights
within two days we now transfer it back
over 25 million swabs so you're saying
that you alerted White House advisor
Peter Navarro about this issue is that
right yes and within hours literally
within hours he had coordinated a DoD to
start these flights to transport the
swabs yes sir this seems like a logical
response to the analysis that you
provided what is truly perplexing to me
is why anyone would resist such an
initiative and that's a rhetorical
question I won't ask
to answer that finally we still don't
have enough testing supplies I don't
understand how and why that is possible
I understand that converting an auto
plant to build ventilators might take a
little time but how can we be struggling
to get adequate supplies of simple
supplies like swabs what does this say
about the federal response to the corona
virus outbreak it says to me sir that
there is no master coordinated plan on
how to respond to this outbreak we don't
have a strategy or plan in place that
identifies each of those critical
components and we don't have a
designated agency that is sourcing those
critical components and coming up with a
strategy to make sure that we have those
supplies when we need them we need this
comprehensive national strategy this
end-to-end about includes every
component to make sure we can respond
and protect American lives
thank you dr. bright your great American
thank you very much I yield back the
gentleman yields back
pleasure to recognize the gentleman from
Virginia mr. Griffith for his five
minutes questions Thank You mr. chairman
madam chairman appreciate it seems like
mr. Navarro's done a pretty good job in
listening to the questions I do wish we
had more of the information available
and it's one of the reasons why it's not
your fault but I wish we had done this
through the regular channels but I would
ask this on some of the questions that
were just asked about supplies being
available I kind of got the impression
from prior testimony the project
Bioshield which you urged us to put
money into and we put 700 million in 18
and 735 and 1519 was supposed to take
care of some of that am I miss
misunderstanding project Bioshield
project Brown shield is used to invest
in late stage development of drugs and
actually early and some diagnostics and
they didn't help on this at all it
didn't help on this at all sir all right
now that being said and I did say you
know and I would hope that we would have
had everything available to us and I
understand it may not be your fault but
it does create issues but but
everything's going crazy the people have
all kinds of things going on and there's
Corwin comes up and there's some email
exchanges in exhibit 54 from your
documents indicate that hey Chris
Christopher Houchins writes and he says
you know we should probably take a look
at this I'm paraphrasing but the line I
took out of it was especially when we
have few or no options one of the
frustrations I have had for years with
our community trying to respond to all
kinds of different diseases is we want
to have the double-blind studies in
place we want to have all the science
there which makes sense if you have an
alternative but when you have few or no
options it seems to me you would go
after those things that are available
and if hydrochloric rain is one at one
point then remand is severe I'm assuming
have they done the double-blind studies
with related to Cove it on rent if
severe has that already happened and
then I've got an article from the
Richmond times-dispatch
April 15th where a doctor used high
doses of vitamin C and a drug called
actor moi also an actor Murrah all of
these are floating out there doctors are
using all kinds of things because we
don't have other options and some
wondering would what was the great
hesitancy to at least let doctors try
and if it even if a knee totally was
having some effect wouldn't you have to
have that available in order to be able
to do the tests and if you've got few or
no options why wouldn't you want to go
down that pathway we want to make sure
that the drugs that we consider are safe
and effective the highest priority is
safety so many of these studies that we
had or anecdotal evidence or reports we
had did not include a thorough safety
vetting of those drugs there are some
known side effects for some of the drugs
many of these drugs were repurposed so
they weren't built de novo so we knew
about some of those potential safety
concerns and we didn't have any evidence
of how those safety concerns would
appear in people in fact it with its
virus this virus takes over a lot of
your body and actually infects multiple
organs in your body and cause a
significant Flamel
organ shutdown in some cases before
death an acute respiratory distress send
them it really turns your lungs into a
brick this is very stuff and you said
the 100 drawer Quinn that you know one
of the problems was you might have a
heart irregular heartbeat
if you're worried about not having a
heartbeat at all that's really not as
you know worried about a irregular if
you don't have one at all am I not
correct about that I mean that's the
concern people were dying out there and
here was the first one that showed some
promise why wouldn't we want to accept
you know an offer from a manufacturer to
give us a lot of this and have it out
there for widespread use
if the doctors chose just like the
doctor in Richmond that didn't work in
that case they actually used it in their
in that case and didn't work so he tried
something else I mean I think that's
really what we're gonna have to do in an
emergency situation am I not correct we
need to do it carefully sir we have to
make sure that when we have does that
information available with those
potential drugs available we are
thinking outside the box
we'd be careful that we actually do
accidentally kill people we need to move
swiftly sir and we've acted the show
that we could put up a clinical study in
the matter less than a week I'm quite
important to use the available clinical
data and if we know there are potential
risk we need to make sure that we're
cognizant of those risk and make sure
those drugs are used in a very safe and
controlled manner yes sir and I
appreciate that and let me just say this
you know it's our job to ask some tough
questions sometimes but you you know
just like you found friendly years at
the white house you might have found
some friendly ears on our side of the
aisle here as well and I would note that
in 2018 you were talking about vaccines
and you were talking about offshore
production and I said let me know what I
can do to help get more production on
shore but I never heard from you I'm
happy to help
I want onshore production I'm with you
on a lot of these issues I don't know
what's going on behind the scenes we've
got to investigate that today
unfortunately it was not the day to do
that investigation we don't have enough
information a lot of stuff is not here
for us but don't hesitate in the future
if you see something let us know on both
sides of the aisle what's going on I
appreciate it and I yield back thank you
gentleman yields back pleasure to
recognize the gentlewoman from
California miss Matsui
for her five minutes of question
thank you very much ma'am chair and
thank you dr. bright for appearing
before us today and thank you for your
public service
dr. bright you described a series of
missed opportunities that have left our
country woefully unprepared for the
pandemics impact many Americans are
eager to return to normalcy as we could
all understand but to even begin safely
we opening we need widespread testing
capacity and organize contract tracing
workforce and a healthcare system that
can handle further surge and ultimately
a vaccine or therapeutic cure is
required I'd like to ask you a series of
questions about your warnings to the
administration while that Barda I'm
hoping you can success succinctly answer
whether you believe each scenario will
ultimately shorten or lengthen the time
it takes for our country to safely
reopen and recover from the corona virus
endemic On January 10th you began
pushing HHS leadership to obtain
sequencing and virus samples given the
importance of these samples for vaccine
and diagnostic development has
administration's in action shorten or
lengthen our timeline for reopening
those samples were critical to get
started as early as possible there was
delay in getting those samples that
means they'll be delay in getting those
countermeasures the countermeasures are
critical to reopening our country okay
throughout the month of January you made
HHS aware of the urgent need to increase
funding to combat the virus HHS
leadership believe that barda's budget
was sufficient has the delay of these
resources shorten or lengthen our
timeline for reopening delay of those
resources have extended the ability the
timeline to make drugs available in
vaccines therefore it's extended our
ability to respond to this pandemic On
January 18th you push dr. Cadillac to
coordinate carbon 19 planning activities
across the government
dr. Catholic initially rejected your
request suggesting it was not time
sensitive did this delay in coordination
shorten or lengthen our timeline for
reopening that length of the timeline
primary opening we need we needed those
early policy discussion
to happen as soon as possible from
January through March to push for HHS to
ramp up production in 95 mass swabs and
syringes HHS failed to act quickly has
this inaction shortened or lengthened
our timeline to reopening that inaction
has put a lot of lives at risk and our
frontline health care workers in no time
to reopen our country we'll bring those
people back to us certainly thank you
dr. Boyd course there many decisions
made outside of these scenarios that
influence when we can safely reopen but
from what I'm hearing today
HHS if they heeded your warnings early
we could have proactive limit at the
toll this pandemic is taking on our
country it appears clear from the
whistleblower report that the Trump
administration prioritized political
calculations above Public Health with
regard to chloroquine and hydrochloric
hydrochloric win despite the lack of
data supporting the clinical benefits
for the treatment of prevention of
carbon 19 the Trump administration
promoted the drugs use to the American
people because it was seen as a big and
media win
dr. bright do you believe there are
other instances where the administration
relied on politics rather than science
to make corner virus response decisions
and what consequences might those
decisions have had on public health we
have a very rigorous scientific review
process for all the investments that we
make for the drugs vaccines and
diagnostics through Barda and through
our department actually and so there
were some attempts to bypass that
rigorous vetting process that caused me
great concern and actually increase the
tension between me and dr. Kadlec
without that scientific vetting that
does increase the risk of a drug being
evaluated or supported that could have
safety concerns and we really needed to
have the best scientist in our country
weigh in on whether or not that drug
should be evaluated and how it should be
evaluated to address those safety
concerns certainly the Trump
administration waited until April to
invoke the defense production act to
increase the production of life-saving
medical supplies like math
months after doctors began experiencing
shortages and three months after your
initial January warnings should HHS have
invoked the Defense Act earlier to
increase the domestic production a
critical medicine medical supplies like
masks and swabs I'm actually I'm not an
expert on the defense production act and
how it's used most effectively I do
believe that we should have been doing
everything possible placing orders early
ramping up supply ramping up production
of those critical medical equipment as
quickly as possible whether or not
that's through the defense production
act or other mechanisms it should have
been a high priority thank you very much
dr. bright I run out of time and thank
you very much for appearing before us
today the gentlewoman yields back
pleasure recognized the gentleman from
Florida mr. Billy raucous like or his
five minutes I appreciate very much and
I want to thank dr. Breyers law for your
service to our country i I have a few
questions and I'm focusing on the
hydroxychloroquine when was the when was
the potential use of chloroquine and
hydroxychloroquine as treatment for the
Kovic 19 first brought to your attention
sir I believe is probably mid-march
between March 10th and March 17th
somewhere in that time frame
I'm not prior to that not that I recall
the first I heard of the the the drug
itself was a call I received from dr.
Woodcock at the FDA asking if I'd heard
of the drug and I hadn't heard of the
drug and I hadn't heard it it's
potentially used for cope with 19
patients she said there might be
something interesting to look at and
she's forward a manuscript and a draft
manuscript and that's the first I
learned of the drug itself so so you
won't you didn't you weren't aware of
any news articles and research papers in
January discussing the potential
benefits of the drug
I heard anecdotal stories and reports
sir yeah I had probably I can't recall
if I did specifically for chloroquine
but I tried to track the media and the
scientific journal as well however
I rely on the guidance at the science
within HHS and the first I'd heard of
that was from my colleague dr. Woodcock
at the FDA and then a summary report
from our scientists at FDA CDC NIH and
Barda that indicated that the Dave
evidence for his benefit was weak and
the evidence for its safety concerns was
stronger and they did not believe at
that point it was something that should
be supported okay now again what was
your reaction personally did you think
it was something worth pursuing
initially when you heard from dr.
Woodcock initially I said that I I do
believe if I mean I trust dr. Woodcock
and her scientific judgment immensely
and if she mentioned that is something
that we should look at and there's
something we should consider testing in
a randomized controlled clinical study I
would be supportive of the team
reviewing that protocol and that
information to see if it should be used
I saw you know I understand I've heard
from experts and I'm certainly not an
expert in this area that that the drug
the one that we're talking about in this
case hydroxychloroquine if it's used I
first of all timely because I know
understand there's a window there as far
as the patient the the effect of the
efekta see of the drug have you heard
this that that if it's administered
properly there's a there's a small
window there for the patients or as risk
is concerned have you can you elaborate
a little bit on that if you've heard
that and again this is not from from a
layperson this is from from our expert
we have seen anecdotal heard of
anecdotal data and from different
positions that they believe they've seen
benefit or patient improvement from use
of this drug in either combination with
antibiotic is it through myosin or a
combination with
zinc or other vitamin C or other things
but there was never sufficient evidence
from a randomized controlled study to
show us benefit would actually outweigh
the potential risk that is why the NIH
and probably 40 other institutions
around the world are conducting
randomized controlled clinical studies
to look at the benefit either in late
stage treatment or early stage treatment
most of the data coming out from those
clinical studies to date haven't shown
an overwhelming level of evidence that
it has benefits in those patients
doesn't mean that it might still have
some benefit in individuals or a case or
two in different studies or that
physicians believe they see a benefit in
their patients but in the context of a
randomized controlled study we haven't
seen an overwhelming level of benefit
have you reviewed the this studies in
other countries such as France and
impossibly Japan on these I mean are you
I just want to know because it my
constituents ask these questions I do
you take those studies into
consideration when you make these
decisions we absolutely do we look at
the quality of those studies we
understand look to see if they were done
with the right controls in place and the
right sample size was it statistically
relevant or was it just a few people or
was it 20 people or was it 2,000 people
all that adds to the power of the data
itself many of the studies that we saw
early you know only included a few
number of patients and so it was unclear
even from the description of some of
those studies that were not in
peer-reviewed journals whether all the
patients were treated the same whether
they had full participation throughout
the clinical study itself and looking at
the statistical power of many of those
studies they were very small so it's
really difficult to understand the
impact the benefit we also saw study
that the VA hospital conducted with the
hydroxychloroquine that showed people
who were treated with hydroxychloroquine
appear to have a higher rate of death
and people who are not treated with
hydroxychloroquine so that study - has
weaknesses no study is actually perfect
you take all of that evidence into
account when you make a decision on how
to further study the driver how to use
that drug it's my understanding that not
my constituent but a US citizen who a
veteran was cured I again this is just
where I've heard from from the drug and
that was a late-stage case but I've also
heard of early stage cases as well so I
wanted to get that on record thank you
madam chair
yields back
pleasure to recognize the gentlewoman
from Florida Ms castor for her five
minutes of questions thank you madam
chair dr. bright thank you for speaking
out to save lives
I read your whistleblower filing and I
want to ask you about the n95
respirators these are these respirators
are essential personal protective
equipment they're not the cloth masks or
surgical masks that everyday Americans
are encouraged to wear by the CDC dr.
brighter and ninety five respirators
necessary to protect the lives of nurses
doctors EMTs and those on the frontlines
yes they're acquired
essential personal protective equipment
to protect those frontline health care
workers from getting infected and this
is not a hypothetical concern just last
week the LA Times reported a tragic
story about a heroic nurse CLO Celia
Marcos who appears to have died because
she lacked an n95 respirator when she
rushed rushed into a hospital room to
try to save a Kovan 19 patient who had
stopped breathing and this brave nurse
is not the only one according to another
report over 700 staff at just one
Detroit area Health System have tested
positive for Kovan 19 and the CDC
reported over a month ago that over
9,000 health care workers had already
contracted kovat and dozens have
and I checked with my Tampa Bay Area
health providers and one Tampa hospital
said and 95s are still very difficult to
procure she said there's a dire need for
n95 so one of my community health center
says we continue to struggle to get in
95s and there's so many folks trying to
sell knockoffs and then a large Tampa
Bay Area health system said the supply
chain remains inconsistent and the
irregular and baked hair remains
concerned as we head into the fall for
n95 masks the the demand will continue
to increase due to the flu season and
the continued presence of kovat 19 dr.
bright you understood that America would
face a shortage of respirators in
January is that right we understood
America would face a shortage of n95
respirators for a pandemic response in
2007 and we have exercised and known and
evaluated that number almost every year
since 2007 it was exercise even as late
as early as 2019 August and crimson
contagion that we would need 3.5 billion
in 95 respirators in our stockpile to
protect our healthcare workers from a
pandemic response and you sounded the
alarm repeatedly but were ignored by the
senior leadership at the Department of
Health and Human Services please explain
what steps that you took and the
responses you received we knew going to
this pandemic that critical medical
equipment would be in short supply I
began getting alerts from industry
colleagues in in mid and early to mid
and late January telling me that from an
outside view from the industry view that
the supply chain was diminishing rapidly
telling me that other countries were
that we relied on to supply many of
these masts were blocking export and
stopping transfer of those masts to the
United States
I learned that China was trying to buy
the equipment from the United States
producers to have it shipped to China so
they could make more in each of these
alerts and there are dozens of these
alerts
I pushed those forward to our leadership
and a spur to dr. Catholic and his
senior leadership team I pushed those
warnings to our critical infrastructure
protection team I pushed those warnings
to our strategic national stockpile team
who has the responsibility of procuring
those medical supplies for our stockpile
in each of those I was met with
indifference saying they were either too
busy they didn't have a plan they didn't
know who was responsible for procuring
those in some cases they had a sick
child and it would get back to it later
in the week a number of excuses but net
to manufacturers or producers of those
masks a five-page survey asking
producers or companies if they actually
made those masks in your whistleblower
filing you discuss a February 7th
meeting of the department leadership
group but which you urge the department
to focus on securing n95 masks people
who should not be wearing those masks so
that would save those masks for our
health care workers my response was I
cannot believe you can sit and say that
with a straight face that was an absurd
in fact it took three months from your
initial warnings until mid April for the
federal government to invoke its
authority under the defense production
Act to require the production of
millions of more and 95 masks and even
then the administration required the
production of only 39 million masks
which is far fewer that you and other
experts said that we would need well it
was a consequence of this three-month
delay an inadequate response were lives
in danger lives were endangered and I
believe lives were lost and not only
that we were forced to procure these
supplies from other countries without
the right quality standards so even our
doctors and nurses in the hospitals a
day are wearing in ninety five marked
masks from other countries that are not
providing the sufficient protection that
a u.s. standard in ninety five masks
would provide them some of those masks
are only 30 percent
effective therefore nurses are rushing
in the hospitals thinking they're
protected and they're not thank you for
your courageous effort gentlewoman's
time has expired a pleasure to recognize
our colleague from Indiana dr. Bhushan
for his five minutes thank you madam
chairwoman and thank you dr. bright for
testifying I appreciate it
I will I was a cardiovascular thoracic
surgeon from and been in health care for
over thirty some years so I want to
comment on no I'm not gonna ask a
question about hydroxy korklan I was
want to comment on how the medical
community responds to this type of thing
doctors across the country will use
drugs off-label in a circumstance where
they don't have or they don't see a
viable alternative to that and I think
this is one of those circumstances I
hear I'm hearing from doctors across the
country and look I'm with you you have
to have double-blind studies you have to
have proof in an under normal
circumstances but in this situation I
think a little bit of understanding and
leeway from the federal government is in
order we do want to ensure the safety
this is a drug that has been proven safe
for many many years in the appropriate
doses it does prolong the QT interval as
you've outlined which is can lead to
cardiac arrhythmias if not used properly
but I mean tell you when states tried to
stop doctors from using this there was
such a backlash they had to back away
from it because the physicians and the
community wanted to use it and so
doctors like me out in the real world if
things are working even anecdotally
they're not going to wait for the
government bureaucracy to approve it I
just want to get that on the record I'm
just saying this is why doctors are
using this drug whether it's right or
not data will show but you know if two
years from now we have the studies and
we say hey that stuff really would have
worked and the government stopped that
from being used if I was a family of a
person that was stopped from getting
hydroxychloroquine and I'd be pretty mad
I want to talk about the supply chain
issues and as it relates to PPE the
personal protective equipment and I
think there's enough blame to go around
in the federal government about what
happened they
for you know after h1n1 we're national
stockpiles were depleted we didn't read
in replenish them we've had people on
both sides of the aisle talking about
this and it's I think there's some
something to some blame to go around but
you know I don't I don't want to be
accusatory but I do want to go over some
of the facts about barda's situation as
it relates to the masks okay and
according to Washington Post report in
2015 the Obama administration and a
company now known as om Howard how your
H al Y ard announced a project to
develop rapid pandemic mass production
line
according to federal contracting records
in 2017 HHS signed off on a three point
three million with an M payment to how
work halyard to build a machine that
could churn out millions of protective
respiratory mass at a high rate of speed
during a pandemic however in September
of 2018 CNBC reported that the machine
was never built
and despite barda's 1.5 billion with a B
budget the Washington Post reported
there wasn't money to pay for the
project
why was the project scrapped and did you
sign off on that decision so that just
that project that halyard was to build a
novel new machine to make a respiratory
protection facemask faster as you
described accurately actually the
technical team must have reviewed that
proposal on the next step or they in
further investment in that machine I
believe that the investment to date was
made to design the Machine build the
blueprint and machine and I'm not even
sure if it was to build and at that time
in September 2018 were you the head of
Barda in 2018 that was the director
bright so did you sign off on the
decision because I would expect a
decision like that a contract money was
allocated apparently from HHS to Barda
to do this I wouldn't expect that to be
scrapped without the director of Barda
signing off on that right so did you
sign off on it - yes or no Clarice crap
the project sir I don't know what the
proposal was that we rely on a very
thorough vetting process understand why
contacting office so that proposal to
further continue that project never made
it to me so if it wasn't approved it
didn't make it through the proper
vetting process and Barda I did the
decision to end or continue that project
was not brought to me okay I find that
surprising but I'll take your word for
it
Nicole Lurie who hired you told The
Washington Post that the Howard contract
was part of an explicit strategy to
ensure we could search mass production
in the next crisis well now we're here
and we don't have it so we're dealing
with the consequences of that decision
and in addition I guess the Howard to
the Howard halyard I keep saying it
wrong it is my understanding well I'm
running out of time so what I'm gonna
just say is look to two doctors across
America you know it's easy for us to sit
in Washington DC whether we're members
of Congress or where there were agencies
and talk in the abstract about people
dying in our intensive care units but
when you're the physician at the bedside
and there is a medication that has
promise and that has a safety profile
that we understand doctors will use this
medication off you know off line and
that's what's happening and you know
whether that's right or wrong we might
take us years to prove but in the
meantime people can die so I yield back
my time is expired it's a pleasure to
recognize the gentleman from Maryland
mr. sarbanes for his five minutes of
questions thank you madam chair dr.
bright welcome back to this committee
the United States government employs
millions of dedicated public servants
working together to achieve our shared
goals as a nation to promote effective
government and to protect the public
interest in this instance to protect the
public health as a scientist and public
health official that was your charge and
you took it seriously
unfortunately the record shows that your
superiors at HHS and potentially beyond
instead of valuing your expertise and
experience squandered it in ways that in
this moment in the face of this crisis
amount to gross negligence they ignored
your science-based pleas to pursue
critical strategies for example your
repeated calls to obtain virus samples
from China and to find supplies mass
respirator swabs they dismissed your
science-based warnings about pursuing
unproven strategies they dismissed your
concern for example about the stampeding
towards hydroxychloroquine we've heard
about that today and they sent you on
errant missions to find treatments with
little therapeutic value all for the
sake of satisfying political cronies and
you've testified about the miracle cure
drug that was an example of that
ignoring dismissing your input was not
harmless malpractice because there's
every reason to believe that if that
input had been heated particularly your
pleas for action in the early days of
the pandemic it might have saved
thousands of lives I want to thank you
for coming forward I want to thank you
for blowing the whistle and the
misguided and chaotic responds to this
pandemic I am sure there are specific
conversations emails moments in time
that you remember like they happened
yesterday the inflection points where if
the response to your warnings have been
heated things might have been different
and I'm sure they haunt you and keep you
up at night from January of this year
tell me about just one specific moment
when you had that sinking feeling in the
pit of your stomach because you were not
seeing the response that you knew needed
to happen congressman I'll never forget
the emails I've received from her Mike
bowing and indicating that we are we are
mask supply or in 95 rest / supply was
was completely decimated and he said
we're in deep [ __ ] the world is and we
need to act and I've pushed that forward
to the highest levels I could an HHS and
got no response from that moment I knew
that we were going to have a crisis for
our health care workers because we were
not taking action we were already behind
the ball that was our last window of
opportunity to turn on that production
to save the lives of those health care
workers and we didn't act listening to
your testimony gives me chills because
it all adds up to one inescapable
conclusion it didn't have to be this way
there was another path things could have
gone differently the federal response to
the pandemic could have been much more
effective so here we are at a moment
when our country needs the kind of
expertise and science-based guidance
that you and others like you can offer
us these voices are too often being
sidelined things are upside-down in you
we have someone who made the right call
in the early days and has been removed
from your position while so many people
who made the wrong call still have their
jobs
dr. bright when the council that you and
others offer is cast aside and I know
you know this it means that science and
reason are also being cast aside that's
a dangerous impulse it's an attitude
that deprives our country in this
critical moment of any real chance of
getting ahead of this pandemic but
hopefully we can learn from this there's
still time to put science and reason
back into the national strategy for
fighting kovat 19 we need people like
you to help lead us through this the
federal response has got to get smarter
it has to put science ahead of politics
and cronyism and wishful thinking our
committee will continue to press for
that in the days ahead and I know that
you want to look forward so tell us what
can we do now to learn from the mistakes
of January in February and March and
make sure that we navigate and lead our
country through this public health
crisis
we need to install an empower leadership
we need to unleash the voices of the
scientists in our public health system
in the United States so they can be
heard and their guidances need to be
listened to
and we need to be able to convey that
information to the American public so
they have the truth about the real risk
and dire consequences of this virus and
they have the truth about the
consequences of their actions if they
don't follow those guidances and we
don't have a single point of leadership
right now for this response and we don't
have a master plan for this response so
those two things are absolutely critical
I would also encourage Congress to
ensure there is oversight in this
response large sums of funding have been
become available to help us as
scientists and others respond to this
outbreak and without proper oversight of
those dollars I'm concerned that they
could be misdirected and lost and not
put to the right fight so I would
encourage Congress to continue and
increase their oversight and how those
funds are being spent and making sure
they're prioritized and use
appropriately to end this pandemic
thanks for that caution I yield back the
gentleman's time has expired and he
yields back
pleasure to recognize the gentlewoman
from Indiana miss Brooks for five
minutes for her questions thank you
madam chairwoman dr. Bray with all due
respect the Vice President was named the
head of the coronavirus White House Task
Force which was actually a
recommendation from a bipartisan Blue
Ribbon study piano that issued
recommendations years ago and thought
the office of the vice president ought
to be in charge of the response and so
with all due respect I believe there
there is that coordination and part of
what I'm very very concerned relative to
this here
is that there's the impression being
made that there's been no plan and in
fact that's part of what the
reauthorization of Papa that I worked
closely with you dr. kavlock that
congresswoman su dr. Burgess so many of
us relied on you all to share with us
what we needed to do to reauthorize Papa
which most members of Congress really
didn't know what that was
pandemic all-hazard preparedness act
most members of Congress and most
members of the American public didn't
know we had strategic national stockpile
x' and that we might actually be short
some of these things until this all hit
but we did get that reauthorized and it
was signed into law in June of nineteen
do you recall that yes and dr. bright
you joined Barda to lead the influence
of division 2010 right after h1n1
because of your expertise and we rely on
your expertise and you became director
in 2016 after and you mentioned it in oh
seven but after the 2009 h1n1 pandemic
the supply of mass in the strategic
national stockpile was not resupplied
you've mentioned that actually we've had
a problem since those seven so but I
have to share with you
members like congresswoman su and I
who've had discussions about this many
of us really didn't know that we as
members of this committee did not know
and were not told of these shortages of
mass as we worked through
reauthorization of this important law
were you aware of this issue and did you
push HHS to maintain mass production for
purposes of replenishing the strategic
national stockpile before this happened
in January before 2017 we actually held
a annual review of the strategic
national stockpile that was chaired by
dr. Laurie at the previous asper since
we moved the strategic national
stockpile from the CDC management
under the aspirin management we have not
yet had an interagency across
departmental review of the supplies in
that strategic national stockpile we
went through an annual prioritization
process there has always been limited
funding and never enough to completely
top off the stockpile you know doc did
you know Gregg Braille I do
he retired yes prior to all of this
happening he led the strategic national
stockpile did you have conversations
with Gregg Burrell from 2009 until 2020
about what was in the strategic national
stockpile absolutely the flu risk
management meeting met on a monthly
basis and each year they reviewed and
prioritized items that should be
purchased by the strategic national
stockpile okay that body which I
actually directed for some time made
recommendations and prioritization
through the strategic national stockpile
however was the strategic national
stockpile responsibility to make those
purchases and how about fem see does
Barda participate in FEM C and would you
please very very briefly because my time
is limited explain what fem see is this
is a plan that experts like yourselves
participate in so I want the American
people to know there have been plans
there have been plans that fem Z had
forth a 2017-18 implementation plan the
White House put forth the in September
of 2018 a national bio defense plan did
you participate in that national bio
defense plan I did and many of us did
and and it was the first time that our
country had actually put forth a
national bio defense plan many said it
was kind of landmark and same thing with
FEM C putting forth mini plans so I want
the American people to know a lot of
folks over a long period of time have
been focused but yet we did not still
have enough we didn't have enough swabs
we didn't have enough mass we don't have
enough gowns for all of those incredible
health care providers so I don't want
everyone to be given the impression that
you raise the flag just in January okay
when you saw it was short because
you hadn't gotten the job done prior to
January and you were at those tables as
were so many others this happened over a
very very long period of time and those
of us have been very disappointed to
learn what was and was not in the
strategic national stockpile I thank you
for your service I thank you for your
expertise but across the board over many
administrations we did not do enough and
I yield back
do you want to respond doctor I could
say that those plans have been in place
and it's disappointing they were not
pulled out in January of this year and
followed they were not put on the table
with a strong leader indicating these
are our plans everyone fall in line and
follow through with this plan I can also
I think is important to emphasize that
the fem a-- c is the public health
emergency medical countermeasure
enterprise which in comprised of many
great scientists from across our
government to put these plans in place
but since 2017 we have largely disbanded
and dismantled that FEM c organization
we have not had those interagency
discussions for a number of years the
executive Enterprise Committee and the
executive leadership committee we may
have had one or two meetings at most in
a new restructure to reorganized MC
organization so the partners and
colleagues across government haven't had
those venues to even talk or coordinate
for a number of years to understand what
that plan looked like and how they would
work together to implement that plan
when the day came to need it okay the
gentlewoman's time has expired and she's
yielded back pleasure to recognize the
gentleman from New Mexico mr. Lujan for
your five minutes of questions I think
thank you madam chair
dr. bright you've described pressure
from senior Trump administration
officials to promote the malaria drug
chloroquine and hydroxychloroquine to
treat koba 19 despite the lack of
scientific support for this treatment
according to your account when they are
offered to donate chloroquine pills to
the strategic national stockpile on
March 17 your team of experts at HHS
determined that quote there are safety
liabilities associate
with the drug close quote and that quote
accepting the donation could lead to
widespread use that is not supported by
any clinical data close quote further
one of the public health experts
advising you said quote no data
available support that chloroquine
provides clinical benefit to the
treatment or prevention of copay
nineteen close quote
yes or no dr. bright are their safety
liabilities associated with chloroquine
there are yes according to your
whistleblower complaint at the time of
the Bayer offer the consensus from Barda
and FDA scientists was that it was
advisable to wait for additional
clinical data before making any
recommendations on the use of
chloroquine to treat Kovac 19 is that
correct yes or no that's correct
yet on March 19th the Bayer moved
forward and announced the donation of
chloroquine and President Trump told the
country at a White House press
conference that the drug had quote shown
very very encouraging early results
close quote yes or no was the
president's statement accurate I do not
think that was the best informed
statement in that press conference the
president also said that the drug had
quote been around for a long time so we
know things don't go as planned it's not
going to kill anybody close quote
yes or no is that statement accurate the
drug had been around a long time for his
use of malaria but it had not been
around for a long time for its use in
kovat 19 patients that's a different
indication different clinical outcome
and the drug can behave differently in
those people yes or no is it true that
within days of that press conference you
received urgent instructions from HHS
general counsel past from the White
House directing you to obtain the
authorization necessary to make the
drugs widely available to the public
that's true yes or no did the pressure
from the White House and HHS General
Counsel put you in a difficult position
yes and how did you handle this pressure
while still trying to protect the
American people we had to come up with
the alternate solution that that our
administration would has except yes or
no did the administration respect this
compromise I they accepted eventually
the emergency use authorization option
was accepted by
to Cadillac the administration yes what
I'm aware of and I would agree with that
that the HHS assistant secretary for
Health Admiral Brett Gloria on April 4
said this compromise quote matters not
close quote and that the drug it needed
to go to pharmacies as well as hospitals
dr. bright there are only 24 hours in a
day and every hour you and your team had
to spend on chloroquine is an hour you
couldn't work on fighting this virus yes
or no did the president's obsession with
this issue distract you and others on
your team from your mission of saving
lives
the directive we received a prioritize
and put an expanded access protocol in
place within 48 hours was extremely
distracting to dozens of federal
scientists who were focused on the
current a virus outbreak they had to set
aside all other work to try to put
together this protocol in the 48 hour
directive time period yes or no did it
distract from efforts to prepare for
this crisis including securing PPE and
wrapping up testing and the production
of other essential supplies and
distracted from their efforts in
developing other vaccines and drugs and
that they were focused on at that time
is a different group of individuals who
were focused on procuring PPE dr. bright
just yesterday the president questioned
the testimony of dr. Falchi when
discussing children and schools the
president insisted that quote it has
very very little impact on young people
dr. bright yes or no do we know that the
president's statement is accurate
there's a lot we don't yet know about
this virus and is really concerning over
the last few weeks that we're getting
more and more data out of New York and
other places where they've had higher
numbers of infections the impact of this
virus in children is very different
presentation and outcome in children
that we see in adults and it's very
concerning and we don't yet have an
answer for that but we should proceed
very cautiously and not have any hope or
in knowledge that we know everything
about this virus
dr. bright I want to end by quoting your
testimony quote without clear planning
and implementation of the steps that I
and other experts have outlined 2020
will be the darkest winter in modern
history the darkest win
in modern history yes or no do you
believe this administration is doing
everything they can to prevent the
darkest winter and what more should they
be doing I believe there's a lot of work
that we still need to do and I think we
need still I don't think I know we need
still a comprehensive plan and everyone
across the government and everyone in
crime in America needs to know what that
plan is and what role they play there
are critical steps that we need to do to
prepare for that fall for that winter
coming we do not still have enough
personal protective equipment to manage
our health care workers and protect them
from influenza and COBIT 19 we still do
not have the supply chains ramped up for
the drugs and vaccines so we still don't
have plans in place now we distribute
those drugs and vaccines and we still do
not have a comprehensive testing
strategy so Americans know which tests
do what what to do with that information
and we know how to find this virus and
trap it and kill it there's a lot of
work we still have to do gentleman
yields back
a pleasure to recognize the gentleman
from Oklahoma mr. Mullen for his five
minutes of questions thank you madam
chair and I'd be remiss not to thank you
for your continued prayers for my son
it's very kind of you and I really
appreciate it
dr. bright you're here on your own time
as an individual is that correct yes or
are you currently employed I'm currently
an employee of Department Health and
Human Services and I'm in the middle of
transition I guess you would say between
Barda and the NIH so you've you've
accepted the reassigned position to NIH
that accept that just position is under
discussion at this point I have not yet
accepted that role so where are you
currently being paid I'm currently being
paid were you being paid from out of
Barta or from NIH is not completely
clear to me but I believe as head of NIH
so are you getting a paycheck since
you've been you've been over there since
mid-april right is that correct
there's only I've received one paycheck
sir work from NIH and I think it was
still part part and part NIH I've had
discussions about my on board or
are you at Barda you made 285,000 is
that correct that's true so how much you
currently making an NIH I don't think my
salary has changed it's still the same
so if you you've been over there for
approximately four weeks a month it has
been about three weeks since I was
removing my office said I borrowed it so
have you reported to NIH yet I've
checked in with the NIH director's
office and we've discussed the
onboarding process the fingerprinting
process and we had a call it just said
last evening to discuss a framework of
my responsibilities that they have
envisioned for me at NIH so you haven't
actually reported to work but you're
still getting paid correct I've been on
sick leave since I was pushed out of my
position at Berkeley for for what for a
very high blood pressure and I've been
under treatment from my position for
hypertension or hypertension sir yeah
you're on medical leave I've been on
medical leave this week however I
transitioned from that medical leave to
annual leave so I can manage this
what is annually what do you mean your
vacation time some of your own vacation
time right now I Monday case did you
inform your supervisors about you coming
here today or did you need to do that I
have informed them about my leave status
I have to had the conversation with him
last night
so you transferred from medical leave to
vacation this week or does it start next
week I had a conversation with my
physician about my hypertension and how
we've been managing it over the last
three weeks because this has been very
stressful to be removed suddenly without
explanation from my role in position is
a life change for me and my duration has
been working very closely with me to
manage my hypertension and and stress
and the conversation I had with him last
night indicated I guess I'm kind of
confused there because you say you have
hypertension but yet you're able to do
these interviews you're able to make the
report and you're able to prepare for
this hearing yet you you're too sick to
go into work but you're well enough to
come here while you're still getting
paid from the United States government
is that correct sir I've been under
medical leave until I get that but if
you've been underneath medical leave too
sick to do that but yet you can prepare
for it for
to our hearing I just just having a hard
time tracking that I have I have a hard
time understanding that and if you and
if you have hypertension you're too sick
to go to NIH but yet you're but you
didn't ever experienced that in Bordeaux
right you never had issues in bargain
with hypertension of the level of stress
of being removed it for my position
while I was in bar 2 so this has been
very stressful and my physician I know I
get it people handle pressure and people
handle purse are quite different but as
the director of Bardot I would fear like
I feel like you're in quite a bit of
stressful position when you're trying to
manage a pandemic but you can't manage
that or you could manage that but you
can't manage your own hypertension when
it comes because you got removed from
the office but yet you can still receive
pay from NIH but you can't show up for
work and then also you can prepare for
this but you can't do that I just have a
hard time understanding it I I know
you're a bright individual and very
smart but you are an employee of the
federal government I just want to make
sure you're not doing something to see
the American people at the same time
getting paid from the United States
government with that I'm going to yield
to a ranking member Walden
I thank the gentleman dr. bright your
lawyer appears to have a pretty
substantial binder there and I know mr.
Guthrie asked about the documents that
there are on the table are those the
exhibits to your complaint to the office
of special counsel I don't know what
made all directed to the counsel then
since she's answered other questions are
those they are those the exhibits dear
to the complaint the office of special
counsel some are and some are my work
product and some are my notes and
they're not they're not appropriate to
turn over to Congress so is it
appropriate to turn over the documents
that are referenced in the complaint not
your work product I respect that
to this committee and would you do that
I you asked that question initially and
I said we would look at the documents to
determine whether they are appropriate
to turn over I'm just talking about the
ones that we have partial email chains
we have screenshots of emails I think we
should have the right to see those
documents if we're going to effect
we know the full extent of this
complaint and I just wish you would
commit to turn those over dr. bright
will you turn those over I think I
addressed that dr. bright I'm asking dr.
bright now he's willing to my little
complaint to the office as an individual
or we just want to see what you've
submitted so we can evaluate it
ourselves
sir I don't understand the full process
other than I was supposed to submit it
to the Office of Special Counsel which
I've done so I don't understand the
legalities of other sharing that before
they've had their opportunity to review
that and and we've certainly been shared
out into the public and press as well as
the complaint that's what was out there
I know I haven't any other something to
I don't know the brass but in any other
you know any other investigation we'd
both be going say we need to see all the
documents is a committee that's all I'm
asking
address one no I think that I think we
need to move on the gentleman from
Oregon is recognized mr. Schrader thank
you thank you for being here dr. bright
really appreciate it tough to do very
impressive that you're here
could you describe the tone and
reactions of dr. Carrick and dr. Hayes
are your January 23rd meeting when yet
they had they're all agencies meeting on
ANCOVA virus they could you describe how
up to speed that you they seem to be in
that meeting sir and it was one of our
first meetings that we had about to how
to address the outbreak and because we
had practice I came in with my list of
needs in those lists for money people
and viruses I my request was met with a
bit of surprise and puzzlement
I remember secretary a czar looking
around the room saying money you need
money even but maybe there's money
somewhere I mean it was just something I
should sell fight the fact that we had
had the outbreak in China for some time
this was January 23rd at this point
could you describe by January 25th a
remember
I'll exchange with mr. Bowen on the mat
on the mass situation I don't remember
that specific but I'm sure it was urgent
I'm sure that Mr Bowen was sending me
and notice saying asking if this so you
didn't ask him to come and talk to you
he out he just reached out to you yes
sir okay about an email exchange with
dr. kerr on january 27th did you reach
out to dr. hurt he'd come and asked
wanted doctor he reached out to me I
believe I bet this was because again
he's a pandemic influenza expert as well
response and and he knows the vital
nature of meeting those viruses and he
was involved in prepping our secretary
for a call you had with the minister
Vice Minister MA and China and we knew a
high priority was for our secretary to
ask for those viruses we've had
challenges in the past and getting
viruses from China from avian influenza
strains and viruses so this was a high
priorities we needed that to get started
and he was alarmed when he wrote to me
that morning indicating that the CDC
director had reprioritized and actually
indicated that we did not need or he did
not need to the secretary did not need
to ask China for viruses and it was
alarming to us because we knew how
critical it was now that sounds sounds
incredible of light of what is
transpired Sid said so I guess my major
point here is that we have a brave
individual coming forward as a
whistleblower but he is not alone there
are many others experts scientists and
manufacturers they realized we were in
if I may say deep [ __ ] not a long time
ago long before the administration and
the White House began to wake up what do
you what do you think would have
happened if mr. Navarro had not reached
out to you and actually responded to you
what where would we be now if you hadn't
been able to at least to get one person
White House's attention it's difficult
to speculate where we were so even when
mr. Navarro reached out and and and
strongly suggest to the action be taken
on February 10th
and february 9th is in the email
february 10th it was conveyed to dr.
cadelec that we needed to ramp up
production of in 95 masks that order did
not go out that solicitation did not
closed to march 18th so even with the
pressure of mr. Navarro who I believe
shared a sense of urgency about this
outbreak that pressure alone still did
not spur dr. Cadillac and our strategic
national stockpile into that urgently
needed action oh that's very
disconcerting and the reason we're here
today perhaps last question if I may and
switching gears and going to the other
side of the spectrum well it's been hard
to get folks attention here in
Washington DC and the administration on
the seriousness of this I think most
people now are convinced this is a very
serious issue and I'm a little concerned
we're going too much the other way in
terms of information you alluded to it
here on the vaccines and think some
people are under the impression there's
a vaccine going to be developed in a
couple of months and everything's gonna
be fine I go back to work and I you know
we unfortunately have to juxtapose
economic issues they have to have
realistic expectations at home and you I
think accurately indicated well you know
it can take up to 10 years and you know
the quickest we did I guess was Ebola
and that was I believe 5 years so you
know is it tough question ask I suppose
you don't have to answer but I mean I
took B I don't want America to think
they can just not get back to some
semblance of a new post kovat life until
a vaccine comes out because that could
take years and there's a chance to
vaccine will maybe not be as effective
much like our flu vaccines that you know
with the flu mutant mutating
year-to-year sometimes is it so I just
want to make sure that you would ask you
if you would agree that we can't wait to
open up America entirely until a vaccine
is there we have to use some of the
other parameters you've already
suggested we have to make sure that we
have some scientifically led and driven
decisions on how and when it's safe to
reopen America if it happens before we
have a vaccine I mean if we have a
vaccine faster that's great but if it we
do need to open them
sooner we need to make sure everyone
understands the risk and knows
understands the risk of their activities
and everyone has to play a critical part
in following those activities to reduce
the risk we have to have a testing plan
in place and enough tests to make sure
that we know when people are exposed so
they can be quarantined and isolated and
not continue to infect others and we
also developing a number of therapeutics
that could offer some potential benefit
prophylactically or protects you almost
like a vaccine before you're infected
those are being developed and maybe even
faster than a vaccine and of health care
workers and frontline workers can use
those therapeutics that might offers
them them some protection as well until
there is a vaccine so there's a number
of steps in between now and a vaccine I
believe if we let science lead the
discussion and we inform America of the
risk and they clear guidance on what
needs to happen and people follow that
guidance and there are stepwise process
they're getting back to work and back
out of our homes and he yields back
pleasure to recognize the gentleman from
North Carolina mr. Hudson for his five
minutes of questions thank you madam
chair
first let me say I believe any
whistleblower should be respected and
allowed to be heard as a core component
of keeping our government accountable
and running smoothly but this hearing is
not about a whistleblower complaint
it's about undermining the
administration during a national and
global crisis as evidenced by the fact
this hearing is being held in the wrong
subcommittee and well before the office
of special counsel finishes its work to
disregard the minority so spectacularly
in the organization this hearing only
highlights the partisan and political
nature of this hearing I hope today will
be held up in the future as a lesson of
what not to do and the respect and
gravity that should be given to
whistleblower complaints so they're not
abused for political expediency more
importantly though we have vital work we
should be doing my constituents want
Congress to get back to work so I'm glad
to be here to highlight the important
work that needs to be done heard from an
ophthalmologist in my district this week
about the need for relief she says
she'll consider this year a success if
her practice group even breaks even
long story short we should be examining
the hundred seventy five billion
authorized and appropriated in a
bipartisan manner for providers and what
providers still need and recommendations
for moving forward we should also be
examining why there are gaps and
outcomes and access for minority
communities Fayetteville North Carolina
in my district has a large and diverse
community and understandably the folks
back home are scared because coronavirus
hits some artists why are we not
spending our time today examining this
crisis within a crisis more closely I
hear from providers and hospitals about
issues with PPE I know this
administration has done extraordinary
things to secure more PPE I want to
thank President Donald Trump for his
strong leadership not only to his
administration moved quickly to
coordinate a response but his travel ban
on January 30th was a bold move though
it was panned by his critics as an
overreaction at the time administration
has gone to great lengths to overcome an
inadequate system they inherited as you
testified earlier move quickly to start
programs like project air bridge
expedite more PPE coming in the
questions remain about why there is a
global shortage and what more Congress
can do to support the administration's
efforts to secure sufficient PPE this
committee should be working on that
question we have multiple pieces of
bipartisan legislation waiting to be
considered to improve the operations of
the teaching style we should be
examining why our stockpile was allowed
to dwindle under previous
administration's answers to these
questions and solutions to these
problems are timely and critical to
helping this administration combat this
virus and the deadly disease it causes I
hear from constituents every day who are
suffering under these stay at home
orders this crisis is hard for anyone
even if they weren't suffering from
substance use disorder or mental health
challenges before they were confined to
our homes and this crisis has
exacerbated this problem why are we not
examining access issues to mental health
providers and the effects this crisis
has had on our constituents mental
health dr. bright you're no doubt an
accomplished scientist and I appreciate
the service you've rendered this country
you deserve to be heard and your
whistleblower complaints should be given
the serious consideration any
whistleblower complaint deserves but we
also deserve they have the opportunity
to ask questions about serious
allegations that have been made against
you I'll note again this is not the time
or place for that hearing
the time is after the Office of Special
Counsel is complete its work and the
place is the oversight and
investigations committee but dr. bright
building own questions for mr. Walden
and others political released an article
yesterday stating that your complaint
left out a lot of information in context
regarding agency decisions to acquire
hydric hydroxychloroquine he chose not
to elevate your concerns the officers of
the Spector general but instead kept
selected screenshots that didn't include
full context another example the Wall
Street Journal reported and Annie on an
email and today that seems to show that
you were in support of acquiring and
using hydroxychloroquine can you
elaborate on what was missing from your
screenshots and why you didn't elevate
your concerns at any time to the Office
of Inspector General so the early days
of that when I was aware that
hydroxychloroquine we were interested in
acquiring that driving force used in a
randomized controlled controlled
clinical study actually when I heard
from dr. Woodcock that is something that
we should try to investigate in a
randomized controlled study I even
reached out to a company into a that was
license and proved to make that drug in
the United States to see if they could
donate that drug to the NIH to conduct
those clinical studies I was aware of
other efforts that were on going to try
to acquire some of that drug for its use
in randomized control clinical studies
as long as it was going to be used at
that time for those randomized
controlled clinical studies I thought we
should look into the supply chain the
same way I did with rim death severe it
was only after I learned that that
supply that the bus' being discussed was
coming in from Pakistan and from India
from facilities that were not approved
by the FDA and the drug was not approved
for use in the United States they became
increasingly alarmed of having that drug
in the United States second it was when
I learned that the plan was to make that
drug available through an expanded
access program so people could
potentially get that drug and not be
under the close supervision of a
healthcare provider that caused
significant concern is because of that
and the cascading days afterwards that
we put in that emergency use
authorization with the safety bumpers
and barriers that we can fill
fertile with that that drug would only
be used under close clinical supervision
but in the earlier days in that email
exchange that you're referring to was
before we knew about this information in
Pakistan before we knew it's going to be
used for expanded access clinical
expanded access protocol it was when I
thought our efforts to obtain some of
that drug would be used at the NIH to
conduct randomized controlled clinical
studies so I was relieved that we did
identify some supplies of that drug for
those clinical studies my time has
expired madam chair I yield back the
gentleman yields back
pleasure to recognize the gentleman from
Massachusetts mr. Kennedy for his five
minutes of questions
dr. bright thank you very much for being
here and thank you for your service to
our country
let's ground this hearing a little bit
as of this morning which means these
numbers have increased there's one point
for nearly 1.4 million cases diagnosis
of cover 19 in the United States and
over 80 thousand fatalities experts
believe both of those numbers aren't
aren't under count because after five
months of this virus being on our shores
we still have a systemic problem with
regards to robust testing is there it's
all right
cases many states across the country are
still actually increasing in number
despite that lack of testing is that
right oh you've mentioned your testimony
that quote we missed early warning signs
and forgot important pages from our
pandemic playbook is that right yes sir
you've been the head of artists since
2016 is that right yes until recently
you experience any pandemics prior to
this one over your course of time either
there or in your prior government
service we responded to the Zika
outbreak we responded to the Ebola
outbreak they didn't rise to the level
of pandemic of course not yes thank you
for clarification sir you're aware at
the end of the Obama administration the
Obama team put together a playbook to
try to guide succeeding administrations
and how to handle a an outbreak correct
yes sir you're also aware that there's a
simulation done from an outgoing Obama
administration or an early twenty in
January 2017 with an incoming
administration about how to respond to a
pandemic is that right
and you're aware that the Trump
administration cut the number of CDC
staff located in China from 47 to 14 is
that right
I don't know the exact number I know
that was reduced okay and sir you
referenced already at the simulation
called crimson contagion that was a
simulation done by HHS and begun in
January of 2019 can you tried just very
briefly a little bit of light as to what
the findings of crimson can take
contagion were the significant findings
it was it was actually with the
participants were beyond HHS who covered
broad areas and government and federal
and state and locals some of the
significant findings were the need for
improved coordination and communication
an alignment between the federal and
state and local tribal territorial
governments and the significant need for
protection personal protective equipment
and the shortage and a significant need
for funding and nerd silly and sir that
simulation was based off of a flu-like
virus that was initially detected in
China spread by global air travel and
resulted in the infection of 110 million
Americans leaving two leading to seven
point seven million hospitalized and
nearly nearly 600,000 dead is that right
yes sir are you when did you first have
concerns about the potential impact of
kovat 19 on the United States in early
January and were you aware that your
supervisor dr. Catholic suggested that
the activation of the defense production
acted in mid-january
I wasn't aware of him doing that no okay
would you mentioned that you were had
two meetings with secretary azar I'm
sure you had others but you referenced
so far in your testimony at meetings on
January 23rd and 27th where you raised
concerns directly to the secretary is
that right yes and your secretary was
not at the second meeting deputy
secretary Hogan was there thank you
you're aware the top national security
council staff including National
Security Council national security
adviser mr. O'Brien and his deputy
Matthew Pottinger raised significant
warnings that China was downplaying the
impacts of this virus I did learn in
that in the meeting at the White House
yes you're aware that we sent 17.8 tons
of medical supplies to China in early
February I've learned of that are you
aware that the Trump administration
budget proposal released in February of
2020 called for a cut to CDC by nearly
seven hundred million dollars I'm not
aware of that I've heard of it you
familiar with a memo written by Peter
Navarro that warned of the impact of the
virus yes are you aware that it was
spread among senior administration and
White House officials yes are you aware
that it was on ER about April 2nd when
the Trump administration finally
activated and expanded the defense
production act months after being warned
by you and other senior administration
officials I'm learned that are you aware
that that order itself did not extend
the full authority of the DPA and left a
haphazard allocation process to states
and hospitals to compete against each
other I don't know the details of that
authority sir
as the Cornelius task force actually
developed a plan for reopening the
country I'm not aware of the full plan
to reopen sir have they developed some
principles that the White House is
touted as some principles or guidelines
as to reopen how to reopen the country
I've heard of some principles our
state's following that plan it doesn't
appear that there is a nationwide
coordinated plan that area states are
following sir
so after this recitation of the actions
and inactions of this administration
over the course of the past six months
or so can we possibly say that this
administration has prepared our country
for what at the moment that we are in
and how we could possibly be prepared
for the distribution development
manufacturing and distribution of a
vaccine to try to adjust 330 million
Americans over the course of the months
ahead I think we have a lot of work to
do to be prepared sir you're adequately
prepared thank you sir yield back
gentleman yields back
pleasure to recognize the gentleman from
Missouri mr. long for his five minutes
of questions
okay do we go to you want to pass okay
you can reserve and we'll go to the
gentleman from California mr. Cardin is
for his five minutes of questions okay
[Music]
thank you dr. bright for for being here
today and I just want to tell you that
my family my community and myself we
appreciate your 25 years of focus
service specifically when it comes to
addressing pandemic outbreaks and it's
my understanding that you've spent those
25 years leading teams of scientists
when it comes to drugs diagnostics and
vaccine development and we appreciate
that you when an administration or
decision makers prioritize politics over
science does that tend to increase or
decrease the likely results of the loss
of life in the middle of a pandemic
I believe this scientists are best
equipped to understand how to manage a
public health crisis and I believe
scientists should lead and and therefore
to my question again I'll phrase it
differently if the scientists are not
leading and the politicians are leading
with the final decisions when trying to
address the issues of pandemics that are
taking people's lives that way of
handling it does that likely increase
the loss of life or is it likely to dick
decrease the loss of life
I believe the scientists leading will
actually increase the likelihood that we
can survive this pandemic and move
through it so if scientists are not
allowed to lead and speak up I believe
it could increase the loss of lives
thank you how many times in your career
have you personally
actively said I need to enact my right
to be a whistleblower it's not cuz you
make me think how many times in the last
25 years have you decided to enact your
right to be a whistleblower this is my
first time sir okay I just I knew that
answer was simple and I think I confused
because I made it so simple began the
reason why I want to say that is because
I believe that you've been incredibly
consistent in your willingness to
dedicate yourself your expertise in your
career to saving lives is the loss of
life on your mind
was that on your mind when you decided
that you needed to enact your right to
be a whistleblower the the my I've spent
my career focused on saving lives and
sir everything I've done does come
forward now is to raise awareness of
challenges we have things that are not
getting done because I do think it will
save more lives okay are you aware of
the fact that the lack of testing in the
United States of America is affected by
many pieces of the puzzle in order for
people to get testing whether it's swabs
whether it's and 95 rated equipment for
the caregivers to be able to enact
safely with the public are those all
factors that have contributed to our
lack of having adequate testing in
America they are a factor sir that I
don't think anyone has thought through
the entire plan completely to understand
those critical components for testing I
think there's a lot of confusion about
the different types of tests and I think
our national narrative is focused on a
number of tests and it's not about the
number so much as the right types of
tests and Americans know how to use them
and what they do with that information
and no one has really thought through
the raw material supply chain to make
sure we can sustain the need to test
okay okay your that sounds a little
confusing from somebody who actually has
been working at a high level of the
United States government
in this space that we're discussing at
this moment so my question is if we are
not implementing in this pandemic to the
degree or ability that the United States
should or could what's contributed to
most of that was it the lack of
scientists recommending up to chain of
command or was it the people at the top
of the chain of command deciding to do
things differently than the scientists
are strongly recommending there's
evidence of scientists raising concerns
about shortages and and other actions
that are important to take that were not
being taken is a different level in my
personal situation is the leadership at
HHS and then I asked for dr. Kadlec that
I believe was dismissive at the early
warnings that I was raising okay and you
said early warnings and despite the
early warnings had there been other
examples where warnings and and strong
recommendations were either being
ignored or set aside and other actions
were taken so I believe that I've
learned of others I mean the CDC has
written several guidelines for reopening
America and getting people out their
homes and back to work and and I'm not
sure if all of those guidelines have
been reviewed or being publicly
considered at this point so there's
another example of I think really
hard-working
career scientists and their information
and their hard work not probably getting
the proper vetting and proper exposure
to the American public well one of the
things I have no idea how much time I
have
the clocks been flipping back and forth
but let me hopefully I have a little bit
of time
[Music]
we've heard boasting from the White
House about millions of personal
protective equipment PPE s as everybody
knows him as millions have gone out to
America but fact to date we should have
had billions gone out throughout America
isn't that the disparity that's a huge
disparity and health care workers are
having to compromise their protection of
their health and safety because they're
having to be creative and reuse a single
mask for the entire week or come up with
novel sterilization practices that are
not proven or tested yet so that
disparity actually is impacting our
frontline workers and those are the
people whose lives we really need to
preserve so they can treat others I have
family members who are working in
hospitals today on the front lines who
have been telling me that they are
wearing equipment for days at a time
that they're supposed to be disposing of
several times a day gentlemen they're
having to you over and over so I thank
you very much madam chair and if
somebody could do a better job of the
class I'd appreciate it kept flipping
back and forth I was trying to you're
absolutely right it went from it got
stuck at 4:44 went to zero and popped up
to 121 so I'm watching - my father was a
watchmaker clock repairman where is
daddy when we need him a pleasure to
recognize mr. long from Missouri for his
five minutes of questions thank you
madam chairwoman and dr. bright you
contend that your removal was because
the tribal administration and HHH
leadership in particular lacks
scientific integrity do you think the
doctor felt she lacked scientific
integrity sir I don't think my removal
has anything associated with dr. pouchy
at all I think my removal is because of
tensions and actions I took between my
advisor and my supervisor dr. Catholic
and myself you know about dr. fauci's
testimony two days before at the Senate
Health Committee I'm aware of that
testimony yes if they change leadership
is so hostile to scientific integrity as
you say
as you allege headaches finally dr.
Fouts you've been allowed to testify
forthrightly to serve in a prominent
role on the White House Task Force the
administration and direct ni AI DS
extensive research efforts so I'm not
sure what this is are involved in and
allowing dr. found she to testify or not
that's not something couldn't you say
that again I'm not I'm not sure I'm not
aware of what processor decisions are
involved in allowing dr. pouchy to
testify or not but he was a lot of
testify no he was but I I thought I
understood you to ask me if that was
appropriate if he was not being allowed
to maybe you can repeat your question if
I misunderstood it what I'm saying is
you're saying HHS is hostile to
scientific integrity and if that's the
case and you explain why
dr. Falchi was allowed to testify
forthrightly in the committee if they're
hostile to why would you let him come
out and testify without any no holds
barred I'm saying that my supervisor was
not following proper scientific process
that we have in place for Barda I'm not
actually saying the administration is
hostile against scientific integrity in
all cases so I'm saying in my particular
situation in my azide my claim my
supervisor was conducting an
inappropriate activity that was going
around proper scientific bedding that is
what I put on why did you not bring
these concerns to secretary azar or his
chief and the inspector general why did
you not bring any of them into the loop
say hey I have these concerns sir I
believe some of the activities were not
it's isolated with dr. cat-like I think
some of his senior staff was also aware
of some of the processes that were being
utilized to go around our traditional
review process scientific review process
but what normal protocol in any
situation be that you go to the
Secretary of HHS or his chief of staff
or the Inspector General with their
concern instead of just gathering them
up and deciding that one
you're gonna well I didn't decide that I
was pushed out sir and and and
involuntarily transfer without Lane but
you had these concern so why didn't you
take them to your superiors when you had
the concerns and maybe none of this
maybe we wouldn't be here today it
wasn't easy for any of us to get here
today sir I requested that an IG
investigation as is my claim as I think
it was in 2018
that they look into what I believe was
inappropriate pressure political
pressure on some of our contracting
activities and discussion about
procurement integrity and I do not think
that that was ever follow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when it was needed was that done here no
sir in fact we had governors and
hospitals competing with each other to
try to get desperately needed equipment
isn't that correct there's a lot of
confusion and a lot of competition and
and and bad decisions made to acquire
poor quality product in any of those
other countries that I just mentioned
are you aware of the leader of that
country at a press conference making
recommendations on what kind of
medication people should use I don't
know the details of what happened in
those countries sir so I don't know we
had governor's here
Republicans and Democrats Republicans
like Hogan like Phil Scott from Vermont
who have done a tremendous job but no
matter how good they do their job can
they protect their people without the
aggressive intervention of the federal
government playing its role I think the
federal government plays a critical role
in coordinating and aligning and making
an equitable distribution those critical
supplies I believe that's what we'd
practice and exercise in the past that
there would be a critical role for the
federal lead and coordination to state
local and tribal and territorial levels
thank you dr. bright are you back
gentleman yields back
pleasure recognized the gentleman from
Georgia mr. Carter do you wish to
question or do you want to pass your
reserved okay
the gentleman from California mr. Ruiz
is recognized for five minutes of
questions dr. Ruiz thank you thank you
dr. bright thank you for your testimony
here and thank you for your service to
our country my heart aches for the
family and friends of the over 80,000 in
America who have died of kovin 19 in
such a short period of time
in fact my heart aches for those closer
to me the Riverside counties reported
228 deaths as a doctor I appreciate your
written testimony that states that
science not politics or cronyism must
lead the way to combat this deadly virus
there's been a lot of hype about cures
for Cova
that have been shown to be ineffective
and even dangerous we are now seeing the
very real dangers and consequences of
not making decisions based on science
hydroxychloroquine which Fox News
commentators and then the white house
repeatedly touted and actually
encouraged people to use is Exhibit A on
this list but there is one drug that
appears to provide some therapeutic
benefit REM disappear two weeks ago dr.
foutch announced that REM disappear
showed a clear-cut significant positive
effect in diminishing the time to
recovery my understanding is that in
January and early February you launched
a comprehensive review to assess which
existing drugs might prove a therapeutic
benefit and you quickly identified REM
disappear as the most likely drug to be
effective against Cova 19 can you
describe how you came to that conclusion
who you told within HHS and what the
response was as for that conclusion was
came about by an a technical review from
number of scientists within HHS to the
CDC FDA NIH and Barda
it was also aligned with a scientific
assessment from w-h-o and a number of
global experts who rapidly looked at
every potential drug and ranked Rimba
severe is the drug that had the most
potential for benefit what did you tell
what was the response and we share that
information with dr. Catholic we share
that information within HHS leadership
as well we had discussions about the
actions that could be considered for
acquiring the limited supply of REM Desa
beer what was a response and we had a
discussions about how to ramp up
production of more rim death severe in
case the randomized controlled clinical
study that the NIH was conducting came
through with positives we had a
discussion and what was their response
did anything happen no decision was made
and at that time my understanding is
that Peter Navarro the White House trade
adviser reached out to you on February
7th to seek your counsel you told them
about your top three concerns the
shortage of n95 masks the need for a
quote unquote Manhattan project to
develop vaccines and securing adequate
supplies of REM disappear can you tell
us if mr. Navarro agreed with you and
what steps you and he took mr. Navarro
did agree with me on
I'm deaf severe the n95 mask and the
vaccine Manhattan Project and he drafted
a memo on on February 9 I'm to the White
House chief of staff and Mick Mulvaney
to share with the White House Task Force
Director for HHS to act on REM disappear
occurred on February 10th what happened
next
and did the Department promptly procure
the needed supplies of REM disappear we
did not proceed with procuring any
supplies of him death severe okay you
were removed from your position on April
22nd by the time you were removed had
the department settled on a plan and
procured the REM to severe no sir they
were still discussing so in
presentations about potential donations
inform desapear at that time so what you
are describing is the gang that couldn't
shoot straight and yet we are in the
middle of a pandemic
there is one drug the experts say could
make a difference and in fact has been
shown to make a difference yet the
department can't seem to figure out how
to acquire we go The Washington Post
published an article on the roll out of
it REM disappeared is driving it as
quote confusing unfair and marred with
incomplete medical information unquote
doctors described how they can obtain
the drug and don't understand the
process for accessing it dr. Benjamin
Lena's from the Boston Medical Center
said quote there's no transparency the
process is just a staggering injustice
dr. bright you were warning about this
over three months ago if the department
had listened to you and the other
experts at your agency could this Fiasco
I've been avoiding we would have had a
plan sir we should have had a plan for
that drug and any other drug and limited
supply so it didn't have to be this way
right here's what I don't understand you
were right about the dangers of
hydroxychloroquine you were right about
the benefits of REM dis severe you were
right about n95 masks and other critical
issues yet you got fired from your job
while officials who botched the response
and ignored your warnings stay in
there's not only is this unfair to you
it's completely dangerous to the
American people I yield back my time
yields back I'd like to clarify
something just very quickly relative to
your leave dr. bright are you on a
crewed vacation time now I'm sorry are
you on a crewed vacation time now I'm
unimproved a vacation leave today yes
I've talked to that and you would you be
willing to share the exhibits once you
personally
once you remove personally identifiable
information I'm having trouble
understanding you through them I'm sorry
I'm getting so comfortable wearing a
mask I forgot I had it on would you be
willing to share the other exhibits once
you remove personally identifiable
information yes thank you
all right Joe we will make them
available this is after the hearing
today when we've had a chance to review
it thank you
Oh madam chair will they be made
available to the minority as well as the
majority made available to the entire
committee I never shared anything with
the majority that hasn't been shared
this is a bipartisan issue thank you
madam chair if there's anything those
exhibits that hasn't already been
released to the public that might be
degrading will that be kept in
confidence amongst committee members I'm
sorry I didn't hear you not knowing
what's in the emails I'm wondering if
there's if there's any information in
there that might be deemed to be
degrading would that be kept in in
confidence amongst the committee members
as opposed to being released to the
public
hmm we'll follow the rules and and that
isn't that classic rule 11 thank you
mm-hmm thank you sir okay I now have the
pleasure of recognizing the only
pharmacist in the United States Congress
mr. Carter
thank you madam chair Thank You mr. dr.
bright for being here and thank you your
service to our country and before I
begin with me extend my condolences to
those 80,000 plus who have lost their
lives and their families as a result of
this pandemic and a shout out to all of
our health care professionals as well as
our other essential workers who have who
have put their own health in danger and
in order to provide services to our
citizens
dr. bright is my understanding and in
2017 boertie funded a project with
Applied Research Associates of Abaco of
of Advocate Albuquerque to develop
respirators that could be sanitized and
reused during public health emergencies
such as what we're going through today
however according to recent reports by
The Washington Post none of these
next-generation respirators are
available for us today why is that do
you have any idea I am not aware though
so you're talking with a ventilator sir
that we developed that's correct
I'm talking about those that were
developed at the respirators that were
developed and could be sanitized and
reused during public health emergencies
it's my understanding that that was
contracted and and that that project was
scrapped so I'm not familiar with that
project we sanitize the respirators
you're not for me with that project and
you didn't sign off on that project to
your knowledge I'm not familiar at that
project we sanitize risk okay fair
enough if you're not for me with it let
me ask you this um we've had a lot of
discussion today about
hydroxychloroquine about core Qin and
I'm a little bit confused here because
it's my understanding that this is what
Barda do you want to clarify something
here all right I'll see you okay it's my
understanding that that that's what the
the role of our the the the the mission
of Marta is to to look at things like
this in fact when we in Congress
appropriate a liqu eight money to go
toward this that you are supposed to be
looking that Barda is supposed to be
looking at things that could possibly
have merit such as hydroxychloroquine
and chloroquine and early on it appeared
that you you embrace that and early on
it seemed that you were in favor of
looking at that and I'm just wondering
because of this pandemic because we
didn't have any vaccine or any any kind
of agreed-upon
treatment we we should be testing and we
should that's what we appropriating that
money for would you agree with that that
that's what we're are trying to do is to
look at what could possibly work in in
and work with public companies to try to
to encourage them to come up with those
kind of solutions absolutely we should
look at all options and makes
we evaluate the potential risk and
safety and benefit of those in the
context of a randomized controlled
clinical study and the context of
emergency we should move swiftly and get
that clinical data as urgently and
quickly as possible that we should not
recede recklessly without that clinical
data on this potential adverse events in
an emergency so you're referring when
you say we should not proceed and
adversely you're referring to
hydroxychloroquine in the corkwood we
are we were promoting that can't
standing up of randomized controlled
clinical studies at the NIH with
hydroxychloroquine I worked with a
company to even ask if they would donate
drug to the NIH to be used in the
context of a randomized controlled
clinical study right yes so that is what
Bart it would in fact I think you worked
with the FDA to get an emergency use for
for hydroxychloroquine is that correct
and it was actually approved by the FDA
that was in the context of the directive
we received in the secretary's office to
stand up and expanded access protocol
our clinicians oh are you saying you you
were instructed to do that and you did
it against your will or sure we were
expected to put in place an expanded
access protocol so and in the context
that Americans would be able to access
his drug and not be under the close
supervision of a physician the
scientists at FDA NIH CDC and Barda
worked together to change that directive
to the context of emergency use
authorization with guardrails in there
so patients would be under the
supervision of a physician understood
let me ask you this initially you appear
to be encouraged by what could possibly
be a result of the effect of
hydroxychloroquine when did that change
when did you sour if you will on on the
use of hydroxychloroquine I believe that
we've seen many drugs that could have
benefit and some of these are really
interesting things we'd never heard of
so we have I understand that but my
question was when did you sour on it
when it was determined that this drug
should be made available to Americans
outside the context
close physician supervision so I support
it conducting a randomized controlled
clinical study for hydroxychloroquine at
the NIH when I learned that there is a
directive to make it more broadly
available not on a close supervision of
physician I was when was that when did
when did that directive go out that was
March 23rd March and that's the time
that you decided no this is not what we
should do and we should not be looking
at hydroxychloroquine at all I didn't
think that was the proper safe way to
evaluate that drug in the context of
this outbreak I believe that should be
only done under close supervision of a
physician when we put the eua in place
that locked to this drug down to only be
used in patients under close supervision
position we were satisfied we had those
guardrails in place when an email string
followed a week later saying ignored the
eua push this drug into the retail
pharmacies in New York and New Jersey
and that's when I became more because in
who put that directive now time has
expired
who put that directive out gentleman's
time has expired
you can answer dr. grey which directives
sir that it should be put out to the
public without physicians approving it
that directive is an email string that
had a number of individuals on it and I
believe it first came from dr. as you
are the Assistant Secretary of Health
indicate at the white house was asking
for that drug to be more broadly so was
it because the president was encouraged
by the use of this drug that you became
discouraged by and nothing new was
politics sir
I wanted to make sure that Americans
were aware of the risk of this drug it
was only available and they're very it
is a drug that is indicated and it has
been used by just one and a half minutes
you can finish your answer dr. bright
and then we're going to move to the next
member drug event used safely for
malaria from a number of years we didn't
have a database server but it's being
used in the same dosage is it what a
miss formulary please please and I know
that I'm overly generous with both sides
of the aisle but I think that we need to
move
I mean two minutes of extra time is two
minutes of extra time and I'm not going
to ask that it be shared over here the
gentleman's time has expired
it's a pleasure to recognize the
gentlewoman from Michigan mr. Dingell
for her five minutes of questions thank
you madam chair thank you to both you
and ranking member dr. Burgess and dr.
bright for your being here today you're
doing a great service
I think we're here today because Kovac
is real I share the sentiments have been
any of my Republican colleagues that
have expressed the thanks to the
frontline workers asking questions I
want to look at the last few months
kovetz really real in my state
michigan's the tenth largest state in
the country and we were third in the
number of cases for weeks we were third
and remained there until this week in
the number of deaths we managed to move
to fourth place two days ago which is
not a number anybody wants to be my
family alone a cousin woke up with 104
temperature and was dead that afternoon
there are people still dying every
single day I have lost someone I've
known Sunday Monday a brother a brother
like friend to me Tuesday and Wednesday
and then we hear the scientific experts
yourself
but dr. Falchi other scientists around
the country saying to us if we don't
listen to them we could begin to see
we're gonna see a return you call it a
dark winter I call it I don't want to
see any more spikes I don't want to see
anybody else die I am losing too many
friends that I know and people across
the country are so I want to focus on an
area that's not your area of expertise
but it's mine car safety we expect our
cars to be safe and we expect car
manufacturers to be responsible and
making sure defective cars aren't sold
and if they fail when that
responsibility we hold them accountable
an engineer and a car company realized a
model had serious defects and warned her
management about that we would all think
she had done her job responsibly and if
management ignored her and our committee
found out I will bet you right now we
would be having hearings and if
Americans died driving those cars the
companies would be sued and they would
be charged with criminal negligence in
fact several years ago before my time
this committee investigated airbag
defects and vehicle safety at the time
the subcommittee's ranking member dr.
Burgess said there is no room for going
slow when it comes to safety and
certainly deception cannot and will not
be tolerated dr. Burgess was right then
and our car makers have to be
accountable but what I'm concerned about
is that we aren't applying these same
standards to coronavirus and I want to
learn from what's happened so we keep
that dark winter you're talking about
from happening it seems to me dr. bright
you acted the same way the auto engineer
I mentioned should act you identified
serious problems and then suggested
fixes when it came to Diagnostics and 95
masks other equipment and medicines is
that right that's true and congressman
we still have those challenges do you
believe if your suggestions were
implemented lives would have been saved
and the severity of the pandemic might
have been lessened I believe lives have
been saved if we had proper medical
protective equipment for our health care
workers yes so people died because you
weren't listening two people died
because they didn't have appropriate
protective equipment to save their lives
and protect them from getting infected
the problems aren't limited to just
ignoring your advice the American people
are confused given mixed signals and
quite frankly some day days to simply
deceived let me give you an example
there was a visit to the CDC on March 6
and at that visit the administration
said anybody who wants a test will get a
test was that true then there still are
not enough tests so even this week as
we're being told anybody who wants a
test can have a test is that true in the
United States of America no in fact all
the experts say we are doing is only a
small fraction of the tests we need to
do to reopen safely May I'm running out
of time so let me ask you about vaccines
we keep being told by the White House
that we've heard very very soon quick
numbers a matter of months for that
vaccine to be developed this is your
area of expertise you are a top
immunologist in the world was there any
scientific basis to suggest in March
that we'll have a vaccine in the next
few months there's a lot of optimism
there's a lot of hope but that doesn't
make a vaccine there's a lot of work
that needs to be done to make it we'd be
able to vaccinate people in the next few
months it's very unlikely thank you
doctor gentlewoman yields back it's my
understanding the minority is a sane
reserving so with pleasure I recognize
the gentlewoman from New Hampshire miss
Custer
that's today I want to thank you for
your courage for helping us to do our
job to protect the American people I
want to start today by restating what I
said at a hearing February 26 with
secretary a czar right here right at
that table the key to a public health
crisis is trust and credibility on that
day I urged secretary a czar to provide
clear credible updates from this
administration to the American public
however your whistleblower complaint and
testimony today unveil unheeded warnings
about personal protective equipment
testing supplies and vaccine supplies
over the past several months I have held
countless conversations with doctors and
nurses and hospitals and community
health centers and our Republican
governor and every other person in New
Hampshire trying to get access to
personal protective equipment to protect
our frontline workers to protect our
grocery clerks we've been trying to get
testing supplies and we were told that
because we were not a hotspot we were on
our own and we literally had to turn to
entrepreneurs thank god they exist and
thank you to them for flying to China
and bringing us the equipment we need
that could and could have been
distributed had we planned ahead these
conversations have informed my roadmap
to recovery on how to safely reopen our
economy and key to those efforts is
adequate testing contact tracing
supported isolation and vaccine
development your your specialty so I
want to focus on your role as director
of Barda and vaccine development and
distribution on page 28 and 29 of your
addendum to your complaint
it states that Barda estimated that
between 650 million and 850 million
needles and syringes would be needed for
a vaccine to be administered here in the
United States for everyone to be safe
your team at Barda also estimates it
could take up to two years to
manufacture these vaccine delivery
supplies to your knowledge dr. bright at
this time has the administration placed
any orders to prepare for how a vaccine
will be delivered when one becomes
available to every American I learned
that they placed an order the first
order of her needles and syringes on May
1st in another order orders placed today
and were the amounts adequate I believe
that this is for 320 million needles and
syringes and could you please describe
the situation if every American does not
have access to the vaccine due to a
supply shortage
that situation would be catastrophic
honestly the decisions have not been
made yet who to vaccinate first how to
identify those individuals and and how
to stretch those limited supplies
appropriately and it's not just the
United States so there's limited
supplies when I said it would take two
to two-and-a-half years to make those
that was assuming there wouldn't be
global competition for those limited
supplies those are not made in the
United States some of them so this is a
lack of preparation and vaccine and
supplies make us more vulnerable to
future spikes in Kogan 19 absolutely and
do we have enough supplies to distribute
both the flu vaccine next winter as well
as the corona virus vaccine it's going
to be extremely challenging do we know
yet of the interactions of the flute
full-fledged flu season in combination
with Koba 19 we haven't seen that yet
luckily in this spring polly was winding
down when Kovac 19 was emerging and
without adequate supplies to vaccinate
all Americans for kovat 19 does this
slow down the goal of fully reopening
our economy and getting back to the
normal that every American wants it
certainly brings two cautions and a
significant consideration that must be
taken into consideration before
reopening we need to make sure that not
only the guidelines for reopening are
clear to each individual and each
individual follows those guidelines
otherwise it puts us all at risk
so can I ask you a question and I know
you're not political and certainly we
are all trying not to be political in
fact I'm very proud in our state that
our delegation and our governor are
working so well together but dr. bright
does this virus give a damn whether a
patient is Republican or Democrat no it
doesn't this virus just wants to infect
people and unfortunately a lot of those
people get really sick and many of them
die thank you I'm so grateful
not just for your knowledge for your
humility and for your service to our
country thank you and I yield back
thank you gentlewoman yields back
minority reserves pleasure to call on
the gentlewoman from
annoy miss Kelly for her five minutes a
question thank you so much and thank you
for being here and your patience as
chair of the Congressional Black Hawk is
health brain trust I'm deeply concerned
by the disparities that this pandemic
has brought to light due to our nation's
history of discriminatory policy leading
to differences in health outcomes for
people of color time and time again when
resources are scarce some communities
are forced to do without the goods and
services they need you identify multiple
situations in which the United States
would face a shortage of supplies needed
to respond to covert 19 from master
swabs and other testing materials and
potentially the supplies that deliver a
vaccine when one is ready
during covert 19 we've seen some states
for us to pay significantly more because
they're on their own
to procure those medical supplies not
every state or locality can afford to do
this knowing what we do know about how
scarce resources are procured and
distributed what impact will shortages
have on lower-income communities those
shortages will impact across all of
America and unfortunately it actually
increases the the concern in communities
that aren't a part of the mainstream our
mytab lower socioeconomic status so I
think it has a significant chance of
increasing the risk in those communities
how have you seen this impact the
devastation of the disease in these
communities these communities have at
the data are showing that they're hit
very hard and we don't actually have
that information yet to understand fully
what's behind that or why and it has
health status or access to health care
or or other immunization status or
healthcare status so we're still
learning a lot about that however is
really important to think about when we
have diagnostic tests and other things
available that they are available to
everyone and many of these tests that
we're developing today are very
expensive or are in very rare supplies
so we need to make sure that we're
developing and making available tests
that are not just rapid accurate
low cost and so everyone who needs a
test can access those tests did you
attempt to urge HHS leadership or the
administration to consider preparedness
outreach at targeted resources for these
populations or are you aware of any HHS
administration actions to target
resources outreach to these vulnerable
groups I am I've had some conversation
there have been some conversations I
should say and focusing on on groups
that are harder to reach in a different
socioeconomic status I'm not sure that
there is a solidified plan in place just
yet to make sure that it's more than a
conversation does it sound like there is
in your testimony you recommend
establishing a national standard and
coordinate equitable distribution of
equipment and supplies will this help to
ensure that every community can access
the equipment and supplies they need
that is what's needed
well more equitable distribution of
equipment and supplies helped to address
the inequities we're seeing in the
impact of kovat 19 on communities of
color yeah absolutely do you feel in the
last bill that we pass we made sure that
there was passed in the bill better data
as far as race and not just who died but
who was hospitalized and so on and so
forth those we're hoping that better
data will inform policy how do you feel
like that will help I think that's very
important wise move okay and we're
supposed to get a report 21 days from
when the President signed the bill in 30
days and then 180 days I'm not from
aware of those guidelines that comes in
a different area but I think reporting
and oversight of that is important and
then lastly you've been sitting in that
seat for a while but is there anything
that we haven't asked you that you want
to say it was a really important
question and and I've thought a lot
about that I want I think the highlight
the things I talked about in my opening
statement is we need transparency in the
science and America needs to know the
truth this is a devastating
pandemic and not just her health but
also society our economy our jobs are
our livelihood and if we do not take
seriously the call for action to put
specific things in place a coordinated
national plan for testing and response
and equitable distribution is limited
supplies and ramp up and prepare for
what will be a very devastating fall if
we don't have the right supplies in
place and raw materials then this virus
will overcome us in significant ways
still so we have limited time my message
is we have limited time we have the
ability to do it we have the greatest
scientific minds in our country to do it
we need to listen to them put the plan
in place and everyone get busy stopping
this virus right I know it sorry I've
had three people in my family with it
and I've lost my uncle maybe like 10
days ago now from the virus so it does
definitely touch everybody thank you and
thank you for your patience thank you
the gentlewoman yields back
minority reserve all right then we'll go
to the gentlewoman from California miss
Barragan for her five minutes of
questions thank you a madam chairwoman
I'm dr. bright one striking aspect of
your account in your complaint to the
Office of Special Counsel is the
contrast between the public updates by
the president and secretary aids are
ANCOVA 19 versus the analysis you and
other experts were providing behind the
scenes I'd like to explore this
disconnect and ultimately that the
administration shared information that I
believe was misleading
we need to do this to better understand
what happened and how we can ensure that
the administration provides the public
accurate and constructive information
going forward dr. bright you had learned
of the Cova 19 threat by early January
is that correct yes and according to
your complaint it was clear to you
almost immediately that the quote virus
was highly contagious spreading rapidly
and could have a high mortality rate end
quote is that correct we were
from the outbreak in China at the time
yes and each day we learned more
information it was actually more
concerning and the World Health
Organization confirmed your view that
the virus was a big problem in a January
20 call two agencies including HHS over
the course of January
you pressed HHS leadership about the
urgent need to devote increased
resources to address the outbreak
On January 23rd you briefed secretary
azar directly that funding personnel and
clinical specimens including viruses
were critically necessary to begin
development of life-saving medicine
medicines needed in the likely event the
virus spread beyond Southeast Asia yet
on January 24th in a tweet regarding the
virus the president asserted quote it
will it will all work out well in quote
on January 29th secretary azar
reportedly told the president that the
epidemic was quote under control and the
president echoed that comment publicly
the following day this disconnect
between the analysis of public health
experts and the public statements by the
administration leaders continued through
February let me give you some more
examples in early February he continued
you continue to raise the alarm bell
within HHS about the imminent mass
shortages and the lack of preparations
for the wave of infections that you saw
coming thank you for doing that yet in
public remarks on February the 10th
president Trump stated it looks like by
April in theory when it gets a little
warmer it miraculously goes away and
quote then he added I think it's all
gonna work out good we only have 11
cases and they're all getting better and
quote you have said that experts knew
that the number of n95 respirator masks
needed to protect healthcare workers and
other Americans in a pandemic was close
to 3.5 billion yet in testimony on
February 25th secretary azar said the US
would only need 300 million and 95
respirators that's an order of magnitude
so much less than what you stated
throughout February your continued you
continued your warnings I would say that
your hair was on fire about the dangers
of millions of Americans faced from this
virus but on February 26 President Trump
characterized the number of cases this
way well when you have 15 people and the
15 within a couple of days is going to
be down to close to zero that's a pretty
good job you've done end quote
by March 10th there were over a thousand
diagnosed Cova 19 cases in the United
States and over 30 deaths had been
attributed to the virus in this country
yet the president that day told the
country quote it will go away
just stay calm it will go away and quote
he could have he couldn't have been more
wrong today we have over 1.4 million
cases dr. bright what impact do you
believe that statements by the
administration leaders downplaying the
Cova 19 crisis throughout February had
on the ability of our public health
system to mount an effective response to
the Cova 19 virus
I believe America's need to be told the
truth I believe that the best scientific
guidance and advice was not being
conveyed to the American public during
that time I believe by not telling
America the truth or being fully
transparent regardless of where the
information was coming from people were
not as prepared as they could have been
and should have been we did not forewarn
people we did not train people we did
not educate them on social distancing
and wearing a mask its we should have in
January and February all of those four
warnings all those educational
opportunities for the American public
could have had an impact on further
slowing this outbreak and saving more
lives well thank you dr. Brian wanna
thank you for sharing your perspective
with us today I hope that over the
course I hope that your courage in
coming forward helps our country forge a
better path than a disaster disaster is
course chartered by this administration
to date I yield back gentlewoman yields
back
minority research pleasure to recognize
the gentlewoman from Delaware miss Lisa
Blunt Rochester five minutes for
questions thank you madam chairwoman and
thank you dr. bright so much for your
testimony but also for your courage here
today um as you can hear from our
colleagues there is not a person in this
room or in this country who hasn't been
personally touched by kovat 19 and your
statement that we need to be told the
truth it's probably the most important
statement we've heard all day
because we know that if we don't face it
we can't fix it so I want to personally
thank you on behalf of all Americans for
your courage to testify before us today
and I want to say that my focus for this
hearing is really on three things number
one what have we learned
number two what do we need to do now and
number three what can we do to prevent
or mitigate the risks of an additional
wave of Kovach 19 it's clear since
January of this year
that there has been a failure on the
part of the administration to use the
scientific evidence that's been
prevented by
the nation's top public health officials
to take comprehensive and I'll use that
word again comprehensive appropriate and
urgent action to respond to covet
nineteen one of the most pressing
outstanding needs that has yet to be
addressed is the need for a national
testing strategy
dr. bright in your testimony you
mentioned the need for such a strategy
that ensures tests are among other
things available to everyone who needs
them I along with congressman Collin
Peterson and representative fella from
Texas wrote a letter to the Democratic
and the Republican House leadership in
the House and the Senate and we really
impressed upon them the need for
outlining the importance of a robust
testing plan for our testing and tracing
and while current testing capacity is
1.6 million diagnostic tests per week
health care experts say that we've wolf
we're woefully short of the estimated 30
million tests per week that we need to
get America back to work as safely and
confidently as possible and to avert or
mitigate a second wave of covent 19
which is one of my biggest concerns dr.
bright what are the immediate steps that
HHS needs to be taking to ramp up
testing capacity now through the fall
and what targets should they be held
accountable for I think what's really
interesting about the testing story that
gets lost in the narrative sometimes is
the confusion about the different types
of tests there's an antigen test that
tells you if you have the virus in here
there's a PCR test that says it may
they're fragments and the virus and
there's antibodies test that looks at
your antibody titers are trying to tell
you you've been exposed already maybe
immune to that the virus there's a lot
of confusion and I think the first thing
HHS needs to do is determine which of
those tests is most important to achieve
which objective if the antigen test is
was needed because as faster and lower
cost and more readily available in some
cases what does it tell Americans what
does it tell employers what does it tell
schools about the potential for the nin
dividual who has a positive or negative
on that test and their potential to have
a different result the next day or later
that day there is a lot of confusion
about these tests so I think the first
thing that HHS should do is determine
the type of test and how that test would
be used effectively and then make sure
that we have enough of those types of
tests and they're in the right place and
the people using them know what the data
tell them and how to use it effectively
I think there's a lot of confusion there
and they need leadership in HHS to
distinguish those challenges and clarify
that for the American public it's not
just a test there are many different
tests they tell you different things
thank you thank you and why do you think
that our nation has struggled with
ramping up the testing capacity unlike
other countries and were there
contingencies in place or a backup in in
light of this situation we're in now I
think part of the struggle is waiting
too late to think about it and to get us
started and when we've had conversations
with some manufacturers they've been
very creative and how they can ramp up
another part of the challenge is we've
allowed many of these capabilities to be
offshore and so we have much more
capability of expanding domestic
capacity when it's in our country and
and we can ramp up and bring innovation
to those companies in the US but if the
supply chain is offshore and as a global
need and competition for that supply
chain that also significantly impairs
our ability to ramp up again I just want
to thank you so much for the time that
you have contributed to our country but
also for your courage to be here right
now
many of us are challenged as Democrats
and Republicans to make sure that our
country is safe and healthy and it
really is it really I don't think I've
ever in my lifetime seen anything like
this and it does require us to look back
and at the same time look forward and
make sure that we have what we need as a
country so I thank you again and I yield
back the balance of my time the general
gentlewoman yields back
does the minority reserved all right
then it's a pleasure to recognize the
gentleman from Illinois mr. rush for his
five minutes of questions do you have
your microphone on
I have no no right now I can hear you
okay thank you madam chairman
no no brain it's so good to see you I've
been watching you this morning and it
just amazes me about your courage and
your insight and your commitment and I'm
just so in they're lying to me in the
same room with you you know country
music are impressive and your reports of
how the scientific process was pushed
aside for short-term political points
are extremely troublesome to me and to
the American people
I'm sure I'm absolutely convinced then
that Manu and the Chinese doctor not me
the nun who first raised the alarm
opening Carano virus in China you to me
remember there's two titles on this
pandemic you took the path that was
right rather than the patent that was
easy
and I commend you for it and I said no
no way it's been widely reported that
President President Obama's White House
National Security Council lovely
administration a detail very thorough
document on how to proceed to pandemic
and then you have any input in that
claim oh yes sir I did a number of our
agencies across the government
had input in that playbook and as far as
you know in any of those recommendation
mininet in amman in this administration
I believe some of those principles have
been reviewed and considered but I think
the PlayBook has changed in this
outbreak I don't think they followed
that playbook thank you I think it's
critically important that we focus on
the path forward well we must learn from
the path and correct injustice and the
answer our response SME forward thinking
forward moving and I am and I'm the
sponsor of my punishment home in
nineteen tres I have been working on
development not comprehensive one on you
being our strategy for Momo testing and
northern north tracing and my
legislation bipartisan legislation in
our community groups to her and trained
in paying workers to engage in testing
and contract
tracing in prioritizes hotspots and
medically underserved areas as well as
entities who are locally and as such I
was very interested in your news or
national testing and tracing strategy
and you're in testimony you said the
virus is out there is everywhere we need
two men assigned to isolate it and to
summon from us any more people and when
that I cannot agree with you more Wow my
question my male side of the slope on
the NIH of Amarna I mean that ensuring
that is a question that is really
relevant intoning and I didn't hear more
my when you as an expert on phonemic
uplands
means should me our national strategy
testing and tracing so I think it's
important you've your spot-on that we
need to have a strategy that everyone
follows the same strategy to test for
the where the virus is who's infected
with this virus and then we have to
appropriately isolate that person in
quarantine so they don't infect others
we rapidly need to trace their context
understand who they may been exposed to
and be able to test of those individuals
and if they've been infected as well we
need to be able to isolate those through
a concerted coordinated effort across
the country we can be able to identify
where that virus is who's been exposed
you give those people proper treatment
and in isolation and it can slow the
spread of this virus significantly but
that has to be in a coordinated way we
have to have the right tested enough of
those tests it's not something we do
once and we're done it's something we
have to continually do in a community so
it's not just that we need one test for
every person in America we need multiple
tests and the right types of tests we
need the right types of individuals and
professionals who know how to use those
tests to trace the individual contacts
and to isolate that virus and stop it
from spreading well I certainly thank
you so very much
and thank you for again for being here
and letting the American people know
what really is going on in our nation
wasn't it me I thank you madam chair I
knew a man the matter of my time thank
you
gentleman yields back
there is no request from the your
artists Baker's okay
[Laughter]
it's a pleasure to recognize the
gentleman from Arizona mr. O'Halloran
who is a member of the Energy and
Commerce Committee and according to our
rules we can as members of the full
committee we can waive on to a
subcommittee and so we welcome you this
afternoon and recognize you for five
minutes of questions but your microphone
I thank you madam chair and doctor
bright thank you for your remarks today
your insight your knowledge and your
care you for the American people you
have touched on several concerns I share
with my colleagues about how the United
States has responded to Kovac 19 we must
address the health crisis head-on if we
want to tackle the economic crisis that
has overtaken our country we are going
to need a coordinated as you mentioned
national testing and contact tracing
plan spearheaded by the federal
government to prevent States from
competing with one another for resources
and planning for hotspot attacks and and
other issues that will come up this is
the only way that people will feel safe
returning to work eating at restaurants
and joint Arizona's public lands and
being out in public in close to two
others this flexibility piece is
critical and you can't have that unless
you have a coordinated process in my
district the Navajo Nation has for
months been going under this process and
it's a hundred seventy thousand people
the area is the size of West Virginia so
that all gathered in a group this or
this fallacy that only herb urban areas
are impacted is is and that it can't
spread very fast 16 people died
yesterday in in fact this on a per
capita basis this currently has more
cases than any state in the country and
yet this hot spot is still not being
addressed in the appropriate way more
resources are needed and they're needed
now and they were needed
more than a month ago when we started
trying to get this dug they continued to
struggle to see the federal government's
promise pavements each timely matter it
came through finally but it has to be
timely in order to respond this will
bolster the health system and provide
people with water food and supplies
during this time of great crisis
dr. bright as an infectious disease
expert what is the one thing that the
federal government must do to ensure
that hot spots like Navajo Nation or
anywhere else in our country are
successfully mitigated in a timely way
that this virus does not continue to
spread throughout communities and to
bring back the faith of our citizens of
our country to be able to understand
that we will respond quickly with the
necessary supplies congressman that's an
excellent question I believe that
there's a need to recognize that that it
is a hot spot and and understand the per
capita outbreak of a number of
infections in different areas and not
treat every area in the United States
the same the rural areas the less dense
areas are not the same as a dense cities
such as New York City however you could
have just a significant of challenge in
a rural area or less dense area as you
described in Arizona so I think the
first recognition is to get the data
across the country into the unite into
the into the federal government so they
can make the right prioritization
decisions an allocation equitable
allocation of those limited supplies and
resources to areas such as yours with at
hotspot area I don't think there's a
full recognition yet of how to define
necessarily the hot spots in a
standardized way across the country so
we need to have the scientist review
this challenge and come up with an
equitable distribution and recognition
of those areas
thank you doctor I want to point out
that this enemy goes much faster than
one of our jet planes our fighters go
fast but this goes microseconds one
person to another and it passes on and
on
so I appreciate your comment the
statistics has to be relevant and timely
in order to be able to do that there
needs a central database
dr. bright we are currently seeing the
number of Kovac 19 tests that are being
administered increased nationwide what
major hurdles stand in our way for from
increasing our testing capacity quickly
moving forward and how can the federal
government address these now or with an
a quick period of time it's taken I
weight Mountain Apache are going through
a high spot right now in my district
they have can not get tests and that's a
they've had 400 cases out of 14,000
people I mean that this is a critical
issue please I still think we need to
recognize the importance of the
different types of tests and when we
identify those different types of tests
are essential for what we need to do to
can't isolate the virus or identify
people infect it with a virus then we
need to put all efforts in the ramping
up production of all supplies for those
tests we've found many times that we've
ramped up now test production but we
have not thought about the critical
reagents that accompany those tests we
haven't thought about the swabs we're
asking equipment diagnostic equipment
that might normally run 100 tests a day
to run 10,000 tests a day in a 24-hour
period so there hasn't been a real
thought through plan about how to
maintain that equipment that equipment
now is failing in many places so as we
ramped up capacity to test and we
haven't thought all the way through the
raw materials and maintenance of those
that equipment those supplies then we
can find ourself in a few days down the
road not having the tests we thought we
had not having the supply we thought we
needed so again this is where a
coordinated strategy and plan for
testing comes into place not just how to
use the test but how to make sure we're
sustaining that supply how to make sure
that we've thought of every component if
it's a swab it was a buffer if it's a
lubricant for the for the instrument
itself making sure that all of those
things are considered
and in that national strategy so we
don't ramp up in one area and crash in
another we have to ramp up in all areas
at once thank you doctor doctor and
madam chair at you
seeing no other members to speak I want
to close
dr. bright you've been here for just shy
of four hours of straight testimony and
my observation is the following I think
that you are the finest ambassador in
our country for scientists your
encyclopedic knowledge the depth and the
breadth of it I think as the American
people have listened this morning that
you have given them confidence you've
also issued your warning and I pray and
I sincerely mean that word I pray that
we will work together successfully so
that that window that is closing we will
optimize the time that we have while it
is still open
you know effects are really stubborn
things and sometimes it's uncomfortable
to have to deal with the facts that
we're facing but we the United States
still has more cases more deaths by far
than any other nation on earth and by
that definition we have in my view a
profound failure you have given this
committee a road map today and we all
have been witnessed your integrity so
thank you for your service to our
country thank you for your willingness
to testify here today thank you for your
courage which has raised your blood
pressure with all of the what one
content contends with when you become a
high profile
witness but I think you should rest
assured that you've made a difference
today and on behalf of all of my
colleagues that thank you
and salute you and thank you for your
family being here as well thank you
thank you well asked say yes who's gonna
ask if I could be recognized for
concluding remarks yeah I'd be glad to
dr. Burgess you're recognized and as I
outlined at the beginning of this
hearing there are a number of things we
do need to look into and I hope that we
will this crisis has been going on for
several months we had an hour tacked on
to a budget hearing at the end of
February and then this is the first
glancing blow we've had against this
crisis so I welcome the hearing today I
think it's important to appreciate dr.
bright being here I appreciate him
bringing his guests I do think we need
to look into the issue of testing I
simply do not understand how the CDC got
so far behind the curve at the beginning
and I would like to know that but I also
feel like there has been in previous
administration there was an effort to
really regulate the which are known as
laboratory developed tests and move
those away from CLIA regulated products
to FDA regulated products and there
really did put us behind the innovators
have now stepped up I'm thankful that
they have we shouldn't have excluded
them in the first place and I think that
was we looked back on this that is going
to be one of the one of the failings at
the at the federal level and that's not
a recent failing that goes back to
guidances and rules that were issued
back in in 2012 2014 as far as testing
is concerned and the ancillary supplies
there are tests that might just involve
taking a salivary sample rather be great
spit into a cup not have to deal with
most obnoxious swabs going halfway down
your throat I suspect those cups are
probably in greater supply and more
readily available and then
dr. bright you'll remember I had an
interaction with you in March
I've had people pounding on the door
with all kinds of ideas I have people
want to make personal protective
equipment they turn their furniture shop
into a PPE manufacturing shop difficulty
getting through the bureaucratic
cul-de-sacs at the various federal
agencies I've got a man that's got a
breathalyzer test or kovat 19 I don't
know whether it works if it does it's
pretty intrigued a mobile unit about the
size of a breadbox that you could take
from place to place you simply blow into
a tube and we'd have to have more straws
we've outlawed them recently but that
could be dealt with there are some
innovative things out on the horizon the
vaccine worries me too because I
recognize there's some illnesses for
which we have never found a vaccine h1n1
and I realize that's different because I
was a flu vaccine but that did happen in
about eight months if I recall correctly
the outbreak happened at spring break we
didn't know if we were going to be able
to open the schools in September but the
vaccine was generally available mid
September to early October depending on
what part of the country you were in so
that success story gives me some hope
that perhaps there is there is going to
be like the end of this tunnel in the
form of a vaccine but I do welcome that
we had the hearing today I look forward
to a number of additional hearings the
ranking member of the full committee was
quite correct to invoke rule 11 we will
keep that as an option going forward and
I thank our witnesses for being here
today and I'll yield back the gentleman
yields back
thank you again dr. bright and the first
panel has completed testimony and I just
asked the staff to prepare the table for
our next witness and then we will begin
in just a few minutes
[Applause]
[Music]
at this point the ranking member to
welcome our guests because he is his
constituent so to dr. Burgess always
good to welcome a Texan to our committee
it's always a good day we have a Texan
at the witness stand we know we're gonna
hear we know we're gonna hear the truth
I will say I've been on this committee
since 2005 in my second term on the
committee in the year that started 2007
then chairman Dingell had a hearing on
the amount of active pharmaceutical
ingredient that we imported from other
places in particular China shortly after
that we had a problem with heparin
contamination we've had a number of
hearings on this with lead-based toys
melamine and our pet food and there's
been a number of concerns about why we
continue to use a supply chain when from
time to time it's detrimental to us so
if there's any bright spot in this
current crisis that we're in it may be
that finally after 13 or 14 years we
seriously move to make stuff here be our
providers for ourselves and like frankly
you know America first really should
mean something but welcome you here
today Mr Bowen we're anxious to hear
what you have to say and they made in
America anyway welcome mr. Bowen and it
is your you have the floor now you have
five minutes for your testimony if you
just you want to place your statement in
the record and just speak or read it's
up to you but welcome and thank you for
joining us today it's already afternoon
you need to turn your microphone on good
morning
chairwoman su and ranking member Burgess
thank you for your invitation it's my
pleasure to testify my name is Michael
Bowen and I am the executive vice
president of prestige Ameritech of North
Richland Hills
Texas and I have been in the medical
industry since 1986 and with prestige
Ameritech since 2006 prestige Ameritech
was founded by president and CEO dan
reece in 2005 I'm going to give a brief
overview of my interactions with Barda
and its directors but first I'll give
you some portent pertinent mask industry
history until 2004
90% of all surgical masks worn and I'm
including surgical respirators were
domestically made that year or about
around that year all of the major
domestic mask sellers switched from
selling domestically made masks to
selling imported masks prestige
Ameritech who was founded in 2005
recognized this as a security issue in
2006 we thought that once America's
hospitals learned that their mask
supplies were subject to diversion by
foreign governments during pandemics
they would switch back to us made masks
we were wrong in November of 2007 we
received a phone call from Barda asking
for a tour of our masks factory Barda
was acting on george w bush's
presidential directive 21 the purpose of
which was to review america's disaster
plans
Brenda Hayden with Barda gave a
presentation which showed that Barda was
concerned about the foreign controlled
masks supply we were thrilled that Barda
had discovered the issue until brenda
said that Barda was only charged with
studying the problem we were
disappointed but we took consolation in
the fact that finally a federal agency
knew that the masks supply was in danger
we were very happy to have an ally two
years later I received a call from
Brenda Haydon she started the
conversation by saying we have
tuition her serious tone caused me to
ask her if she was talking about a
pandemic and she said yes she asked if
we could ramp up production and I said
yes we built more machines bought an
abandoned kimberly-clark mask Factory
tripled and tripled our workforce
America's hospitals needed us and we
rose to the occasion we told them about
the high cost of ramping up and they
said and they said they would stay with
us unfortunately most returned to buying
cheaper foreign made masks when they
became available the company survived by
laying off a hundred and fifty people
who helped save the u.s. masks supply by
taking pay cuts and by taking on more
investors the h1n1 pandemic this is 2009
2010 wasn't severe enough to cause the
foreign health officials to cut off
masks shipments to America so our
predictions didn't come true yet in a
weakened state but undaunted prestige
America continued saying that the u.s.
mask supply was headed for failure we
just didn't know when and 2004 to give
my security story more issue I formed
the secure mask supply Association you
can find it at secure mask applied organ
tariffs raising Ben Franklin I told
three competing domestic mask makers
that if we didn't hang together we would
hang separately as China was poised to
put all of us out of business and put
the country at even greater risk cross
tax Gerson and Medicom all with domestic
masks making factories agreed and joined
the SM si unfortunately the secure masks
supply associations warnings were also
unheeded during my quest
to secure the us mask supply I had the
privilege of working with three art
directors dr. Robin Robinson dr. Richard
Hatchett and dr. Rick Wright they were
helpful and he encouraged me to continue
warning people about the masks suppliant
I'll say a little bit more about that
after years of doing this I quit many
times and the only reason I kept doing
it is because of the directors of Barda
they would encourage me and asked me not
to not to quit they said that they would
express their concerns about the masks
apply to anyone that I could get to call
them anyone except reporters they
weren't allowed to talk to reporters
which was very frustrating to me they
also weren't allowed to endorse the
secure masks apply Association dr.
Robinson was going to do so until HHS
attorneys told him that it could cost
him his job
he called me personally on vacation to
tell me that I can confirm that the
emails and dr. brights complaint are
mine they are merely the latest of 13
years of emails I sent to Barna in an
effort to get HHS to understand that the
u.s. mask apply was destined for failure
Robinson hatchet and Wright all wanted
to remedy the problem and my opinion
they didn't have enough authority their
hearts were in the right places America
told America was told after 9/11 that
governmental silos had been torn down so
that different federal agencies could
work together for national securities
but I didn't see any of that the DoD the
VA the CDC and HHS could have worked
together to secure America's mass supply
I suggested this to Barda and to the CDC
on several occasions I will be happy to
answer any questions that you have about
prestigio mount attack the u.s. mask
supply or my interactions with Barda the
CDC or Ric pride and again it's my
pleasure to be here thank you
thank you very much Mr Bowen again for
traveling across the country to be with
us and for your testimony will now move
to member questions and I'll recognize
myself for five minutes
you were already touched on your
acknowledgement of your emails or
description about your actions that were
in dr. brights complaint so I'll move
past that to the best of your knowledge
is the section of dr. brights complaint
about the mask supply accurate yes
should HHS and the administration have
been able to foresee in your view the
masks shortages caused by the pandemic
yes how many of your mask lines are not
activated right now for for my goodness
and as we have a run of run on supplies
you have four lines that could be
working and manufacturing high-grade
masks for those that need them in our
country yes but not like turning on a
light switch it's a very large product
and just spend a moment to tell us what
it takes to bring those up well the
machines were built in order to receive
orders now to activate those lines
explain that to us and how many more
masks could you be manufacturing right
now we we could be making about seven
million and ninety five respirators a
month however again did you say a month
yes a month so say that again the number
of masks seven million and ninety five
respirators per month but again it's not
like turning on a switch we didn't build
these particular machines they were from
China and we got him in an acquisition
several years ago so my email to Rick
right and in that email I said I think
we're in trouble we have these machines
it would be expensive and hard to get
them going but if we're going if this is
going to be back
that could happen so that was my offer
very often especially for lawyers in
courtrooms and elsewhere when you're
going to ask a question they say you
should know the answer I think I know
the answer to this question but I want
to hear your view on it
we've lost we've allowed we've allowed
this supply this very important supply
of of protective articles to other
countries do you believe it's because of
saving nickels dimes and quarters it's
it's saying I call it chasing pennies to
China mm-hmm look what it has cost us
it's cost us lives
it cost us lives it's cost us lives if
if there's someone that would like me to
yield the rest of my time might be glad
to if not we can go to to the ranking
member of the full committee mr. Walden
well thank you Mr Bowen thank you thank
you madam chair and I'll let you reset
the clock to so I don't go over there we
go
and miss Bowen thank you thank you for
being here and I appreciate your
testimony which I read last night toward
the end of the last panel I received a
copy of an email that you sent to dr.
bright on January 31st of this year this
email appears to be the one included in
dr. brights complaint though it is one
of the exhibits that was not publicly
posted by The Washington Post
interestingly enough here's what the
complaint says two days later mr. Bowen
a prestige Ameritech sent yet another
email to dr. bright and dr. wolf once
again issuing a dire warning about the
imminent mass shortage among other
things he advised and I quote this week
we sent a thousand mass to China and
Hong Kong now I believe your email
actually says mil
in mass to China and Hong Kong he
continued in quote in all my years of
predicting the u.s. mass supply would
one day collapse I never pictured myself
selling mass to China I have it from two
reliable sources China's begun telling
Chinese mass makers not to let mass
leave China close quote he concluded I
think China will cut off mass the USA if
so US hospitals are going to have a very
rough time as up to half the supply is
made in China horrible situation will
become unbearable
that's the that is yes certain that's
your email okay in the complaint this is
is cited as an email from Elle wolf to
our bright on January 29 2020 I think
that citation is obviously wrong since
even the complaint acknowledges that
it's an email from you Mr Bowen to to
dr. bright right that maturity man that
was my email I don't know how it got to
him I mean I don't know how it got to ya
I don't know what emails chain you're
looking at but yes that sir that was my
email I was reading from mr. brights
complaint and and I just received I
think what appears to be a copy of this
email it's it's but it I think it's
cited wrong in in the complaint the
email I received is dated January 31st
2020 it includes all the language that I
just read to you from the complaint but
and and and this is exactly why the
committee not only needs all the
exhibits cited by dr. bright not just
the one selectively obtained by The
Washington Post and needs the full email
chains not just the Selective excerpts
from dr. bright because this document
also says and I will quote this is your
email to dr. bright and to Laura wolf it
says and I quote my government strategy
is to help the US government if and only
if the VA and DOD become my customers
after this thing is over yes sir
so madam sure I'd like to submit the
email for the record we'll send you an
electronic copy as per our agreements
here now
now mr. Cohen Boeing I'm sorry
you said you have you want to help us
government you want to help Americans
get the mass yet it appears that that
there seems to be a condition here I
assume that's because in the past you
ramped up things went away people bought
from other manufacturers and so here
you're saying and I would I have it here
in the email my strategy is to help my
existing customers and only bring on new
customers who are willing to sign a
long-term contract my government
strategy is to help the US government if
and only if the VA and DOD become my
customers after this thing is over and
here we were in a crisis as mass we're
going overseas now the US government's
not your only purchaser right US
government has never bought from me
except during a pandemic sir okay and so
and that email and that statement was
basically saying that I don't want the
government to only call me in a pandemic
give me business during peacetime so
that I can survive to help you during a
pandemic did you ever ask for a sole
source contract I have I have bid on the
DoD and the VA business and I
continually lose two masks that are made
in Mexico because the DoD does not obey
the Barry amendment let my foreign masks
made in Mexico because Mexico is a
friend of ours and is called a taa
compliant country where your massive
niosh based on price sir if I could
reclaim my time how long you said it you
couldn't turn on these lines of
manufacturing very quickly how long if
you got a big order from the government
today would it take you to produce mass
three or four months and the government
wants to do that right now HHS is asking
me to do that and it will told them
three or four months yes I'm told I told
him it's going to take three or four
months they only want masks to the end
of the year so I would have to hire a
hundred people to train a hundred people
and then fire them at the end of the
program I'm not going to do that again I
don't want the government to only deal
with me when times expired madam chair I
yield back the gentleman yields back
it's a pleasure to recognize the
gentleman from New York mr. Engel for
his five minutes of questions well thank
you let me get this down well thank you
Mr Bowen I've been listening to your and
thank you madam madam chair this is a
excellent hearing and it's it's an issue
that we need to focus on because it has
repercussions that just continue and
continue every day I hear from my
constituents including doctors and
nurses serving on the front lines of
this pandemic about the dire shortages
of personal protective equipment
therapeutics PPEs as they call them
recently I helped author the preventing
drug shortages Act with several of my
colleagues on this subcommittee
provisions which were included in the
recently enacted cares Act this all ties
together I've used my role as chairman
of the Foreign Affairs Committee to cut
through red tape and bring much-needed
supplies like a hundred thousand
antibody tests for New York City from
China all these act of actions as you
point out Mr Bowen are symptoms of a
larger problem most US medical products
are manufactured abroad and as this
pandemic is highlighted this leaves the
United States vulnerable in public
health crises and obviously poses a
national security threat the way I look
at it so Mr Bowen as we can tell this
afternoon and reading about you things
you've said things you've written you've
certainly been a leading advocate for
this issue specifically as it pertains
to face masks which you've never been
more in demand than now mine over there
um in your written testimony you note
that in 2004 major domestic surgical
mask sellers switched from making
surgical masks masks domestically to
importing them I know you spoke a little
bit about it but could you go into more
detail and explain what prompted this
change mask companies wanting to make
more profit so they go to countries well
it's not just mask companies it's it's
people are in the hospital industry who
are competing for contracts for supplies
and it's a bid type situation most of
the time and the way you make products
cheaply is to make them in China and
Mexico and other places so that's why
the u.s. mask supply left it wasn't a
coordinated effort it was a bunch of
companies coincidentally deciding to
save money at the same time and and
destroying maybe 4,000 jobs America and
putting the u.s. mask apply under
foreign control and that's been my
message since 2006 actually well it's
really unbelievable because it isn't
just foreign control it's a very large
degree to China control when we look at
again I'm chairman of the Foreign
Affairs Committee when we look at the
geopolitical parts of the world China is
probably the biggest adversary to the
United States so not only are we leaving
it in their hands we're leaving it in
the hands of an adversary we're sort of
beholden to that to that country and I
cannot think of much that's more
dangerous than that so I'm sure you
agree China controls most of the world's
mask supply China can sell a box of
masks for a dollar a box or let me say
this China sells $1 a box of masks for
$1 I don't think anybody's making any
profit doing that because I sell them
for about $5 so it's their prices are so
cheap that they've captured most of the
world's
mass-market as their government
subsidized the Chinese government the
Beijing government I don't know that I
don't know all I know is their masks
cost less than the materials if I take
my labor cost totally out I'm still
nowhere near the cost of their products
do the Chinese masks meet our standards
some do some don't what steps can the
federal government take to incentivize
more medical manufacturing of critical
equipment like surgical face masks in
the United States well as in a letter
that I sent to President Obama I don't
think it requires money I think it
requires the government saying and it's
a national security problem
it requires the CDC telling America's
hospitals they are too dependent on
foreign made masks and put them in legal
liability they have to protect their
patients and staff if in a public forum
like this you say this is a national
security issue then those hospitals
attorneys are probably going to get on
the ball and tell their hospitals to buy
american-made products and they don't
cost that much the whole market is only
a couple of hundred million dollars this
whole problem this is a 30 million
dollar problem folks just for people
trying to save pennies across the whole
United States it's not it's not it's not
some multi-billion dollar problem do you
repeat that again and lean forward into
that microphone so that everybody hears
it again I said this was a 30 million
dollar problem it's not billions and
billions of dollars I've never asked for
money and in a letter to President Obama
and I wrote president let trump as well
but in a letter to President Obama and I
said that isn't this isn't about money
this is about information tell America's
hospitals that they can't they are going
to be in a position to not be able to
protect their staff and their patients
and their attorneys those Hospital
attorneys will tell their hospitals to
buy american-made masks I don't need
your money don't need subsidies just
tell people about the problem now it's
my problem with with Barda not my
problem Barda wanted to do it
they weren't allowed to do it we need
this issue needed publicity and try to
get him to talk to the infection control
Prevention magazine infection control
today sorry I wanted them to talk the
New York Times every time we had some
kind of a flu bump I wanted them to be
able to talk and they couldn't do it
well thank you very much your testimony
has certainly been very enlightening I
know the chairwoman and I were kind of
looking at each other and almost in
disbelief and I certainly think that
this is something that the Congress has
to get involved with and then sooner the
better thank you very much here can I
point out something sure you know I
watch I watched all of this in a room a
little while ago and seemed like
everybody who was beating up on on mr.
bright dr. bright was a Republican and
everybody who was defending him was a
Democrat I'm a Republican I've voted for
President Trump and I admire dr. Brian I
don't know what he did and all of his
other activities but I think everything
I've heard and every time I talked to
him and everything he said here made a
lot of sense and I believe him
Thank You mr. Bruin I now have the
pleasure of recognizing the gentleman
from Kentucky mr. Guthrie for his five
minutes of questions thank you very much
appreciate the appreciate you come in
today I have a manufacturing background
myself and and I know that the
president's asked General Motors and
Ford to make ventilators and and
everybody's businesses their business
they make decisions based on what's
right for their business but it you know
during a pandemic there isn't upload and
if every business person says we're not
going to adjust our lines for a pandemic
and understand Ford and GM have
different access to capital than some
others a it just something that that
everybody needs to be concerned about
because in a pandemic you do have
increased orders but I understand you
want some long-term guarantees as well
but it but there are a lot of people
making decisions there are people now
with their businesses shut down because
of what's going on the pandemic
but I'm just trying to understand the
mask manufacturer process and so if you
can do my questions are what mess what
type of masks you manufacturer and do
they represent the totality of mass
variations salt by the strategic
national stockpile and if you can get
all these questions then do you make all
masks that are in demand that other
domestic products producers make the
only math that I don't make is a cone
style mask the hard cone style all the
masks like you all are wearing we make
all of those and we make n95 respirators
yes in our factory used to make 87% of
the u.s. mask supply hmm so as you know
the strategic national stockpile
procedure procures medical
countermeasures and other supplies to be
deployed in a public health agency yes
sir I understand you worked with dr.
bright at Barda to get federal funding
to produce mass did you have any
conversations with Stephen Adams the
acting director of the NASA strategic
national stockpile let me go back before
that on the strategic national stockpile
I met with Greg Burrell face to face
five or six years ago and Greg Burrell
had no problem whatsoever buying Chinese
masks and I had had a conversation with
him in the hallway after a meeting when
I said don't you find it don't you find
this a problem that America is dependent
on Chinese man masks and he said no I
don't and I as far as mr. Adams I
believe I may have emailed him I don't
know sir the last hundred days I've been
I've talked to so many people I don't
know what day it is most of the time so
you thought it wasn't this necessary to
go see dr. bride you couldn't get
anybody else to listen to him and dr.
bright under well no no no you got it
all wrong
first of all I wasn't looking fine wrong
I'm just trying to find the information
oh yeah I wasn't looking for business I
opened my email
I don't need your business my phones are
ringing off the wall mm-hmm I'm just I
thought of Barda dr. Robinson dr.
hatchet and dr. Wright
I thought of them as brothers and arms I
knew they couldn't buy my products I
knew that but they were the only people
who believed it uh-uh-uh-uh-uh I would
like everybody to go to youtube put in
Michael Burgess and prestige Ameritech
you'll see mr. Burgess talking at our
factory ten years ago you'll see him say
that and that only 10% of the mask apply
is made in the United States I talked to
Michael Burgess Ron right Joe Barton
Patrick Leahy my my associate Matt
Carlin talked to chuck schumer I wrote I
wrote Barack Obama several 20 letters
wrote President Trump and everybody in
his early administration the defense
secretary mattis SEC General Jeffrey
Clarke Nicole Lurie Anita Patel with CDC
National Academies of science Gregg
Burrell hundreds of hospitals hospital
person group purchasing groups the
hospital risk managers Association
hospital risk managers Association told
him the mass supply was going to
collapse this is a risk nobody listened
association of operating the nurses the
Defense Department the veterans
Department Texas Governor Rick Perry
state Texas rep Bill zedler by the way
bill zedler bill Zeller got it dozens of
reporters I've been on every news show
I've done this for 13 years nobody
listened and and and my conscience is
clean mr. grote mr. Guthrie I've been
working on this damn issue for 13 years
trying to save lives nobody listened and
now that I'm not gonna take any of this
what you're trying to do I'm not sure
what I'm trying to do I'm sorry I'm you
trying to find out about who you talked
with them in for so on well the issue is
is that we do have to figure out what's
strategic and what move forward and and
there is a lot of stuff not just amassed
a lot of stuff come from China a lot of
our pharmaceuticals and so moving
forward and that's something this
committee needs to dig in to move
forward and figure out wants to moving
forward but I'm not sure what you are
accusing me of trying to do but I'll
yell back apologize if I offended you I
didn't intend to
the gentleman yields back I think my
colleagues will agree that my
description of Mr Bowen is that he's a
force of nature I mean he has refused to
give up since what year 2006 you began
your crusade 2006 2006 it's a pleasure
to recognize the gentlewoman from
California miss Matsui for her five
minutes of questions
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]